Amy Young,
Jimmy,
fix this fucking mess we have here.
Electronics fail folks.
They just,
they judge do sometimes they just go bad
on you.
They just feel,
that's why people like mechanical shit,
like cars with a collage,
they fail to,
they fail to.
He did three boards,
three boards.
Young Jamie had a fire through a bunch
of shit we have laying around.
Luckily we almost have enough.
If you're listening to this,
you're like,
this is in mono.
It's not even in Stereo.
Is it?
Stairs like mine.
Now I'm going to sound like shit.
Well you're in like one ear only.
What?
I can only get us to one from what I own
over here.
How do you sound to the regular people?
I'll fix it later.
I think it should be just fine,
but for right now I'm only going to be
left here.
Well,
if anybody's listening to the youtube on
headphones,
that means you're probably at work and
you fucking off.
So that's what happens.
He's definitely not working.
Do you know how many people listen to
podcasts while they're working and don't
really work?
Do you know how many people messaged me
about how they're doing something pretty
dangerous and they're sitting there like
I'm doing fork lifts and moving shit
around,
but I'm laughing,
listening.
Really comforting man.
But at least they're,
well if you work at forklift you really
need to listen to people.
No,
I guess not have those headsets on it
and we'll have a good laugh.
I think a lot of them say they have a
policies where someone will tell them,
hey one ear free,
you know,
so that you can hear someone screaming
my legs under this thing right now.
You know,
that kind of shit.
Isn't that the rule when you drive him?
Like you're not allowed to have like
full headsets on as supposed to yeah.
You can have one in I guess you can.
You definitely,
yeah.
Legally drive.
I don't know.
Legally I'm guessing.
What am I a lawyer?
Yeah,
it'd be a great lawyer.
Thank you.
That would,
I would fucking argue to the end.
I think if you became a lawyer and you
were arguing all the time,
you'd probably be a nightmare to be
around.
Cause you probably always trying to win.
Oh for sure.
Yeah.
That's what they do,
right,
is what they do.
Find their way out of technicalities.
You're a shrink too and you're,
you know,
every,
every conversation you get in,
are you psychoanalyzing everybody
probably,
right?
Yes,
for sure.
That's got to wear out on you other
people for Awhile.
Like will you knock it the fuck off?
Yeah.
Well when I was in college that was the
area.
I'm never really applied myself at
college at all.
But the one thing that I was thinking
of,
like if I had a job,
like what,
what are things that I'm interested in?
Psychology did come up because I'd read
a lot of like self help books and
psychology books while I was fighting to
try to like manage my mind and anxiety
and shit like that.
But then I thought about it,
I'd be like,
you just be dealing with people with
problems all the time and you don't,
I don't necessarily want that.
I don't,
I don't think that's a good idea.
Just make you dicks off.
That's why.
Yeah.
When someone tells you their problems.
I always feel like if you tell me your
problems,
you're making my Dick's off problems
make you dig stuff.
I've never,
well,
I always felt like that when I was
dating.
You know?
It's like,
oh,
the girl,
she starts telling you problems.
You're like,
man,
you're making that ticks off.
Right.
Depends on what the problems are.
The problems are they ex boyfriend?
He just never wanted to eat my pussy.
I don't know.
That's a good problem.
That's a problem.
That makes it the car,
Babe.
We got solutions.
We've got solutions for this problem.
Problems,
mathematics.
I've never heard that before.
Thank you.
But now
that's an original problems.
Make my Dick Stop.
You should make a song.
I've written a few lyrics.
I really have.
What does it wrap or the way that I had
it written out is that it's one of those
songs that starts with banter between
like the piano player and the guy on the
mic and he's like,
yeah,
you know,
hey joe,
how'd it go last night?
He's like,
ah,
man.
You know,
she came over,
but you know there's nothing I hate.
Listen,
I hate more than proud was right.
Aww.
Yeah man.
Then you hear a little sprinkle of the
piano,
you'll problems make my dick so dick.
So that can actually be a funny song.
I think so.
Yeah.
Definitely.
You seen the team up with somebody?
Yeah.
Well that's a sure sign that someone is
not really into turning you on.
Yes.
They get together with you and then just
start whining and complaining.
Exactly.
Get your freak on.
Especially if it's early on and you're
wondering,
you're like,
I don't know where we stand.
And they start,
if it's a girl is downloading the
problems,
she's not interested in that deck at all
or she's just so into herself that you
just got to get out of there anyway.
Yeah.
Time to bail.
Because when you tell someone about your
problems,
aren't you thinking while you're telling
them like,
I don't want to fucking burden this guy
with my problems.
Right?
Yes.
So when someone doesn't think like that,
they're very self obsessed.
That's just thinking about themselves.
That's true.
And I told her,
I can fuck you.
You fucking,
he only my boss because you're
okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Then you're like,
look,
I made a souffle.
What's up are going to do,
especially at work problems when people
start talking about work bullshit,
like you're not even there.
You have it.
That when you go on a,
you know,
double date,
real life and then they start telling
you about Sarah and accounting or
something and your dude double dates can
be fucking rude.
All and especially the ones my wife
wants to set setup.
Can I leave me leave to meet my husband?
They don't realize you're your
conditioned pretty much fully to
interesting people.
Your,
you know,
your host a podcast.
Do you have guests on?
You have a lot of people.
You're friends with Comedians,
so you have funny,
insightful people all the time.
I can write here and then,
and then you have a,
you know,
then you're in the fight world and you
have,
you know,
people,
things,
people talking about things that
interest you.
Yes.
And if you go on a double date with
someone who doesn't check off any of
those things,
that can be real
fucking downer.
Some people just don't know how to tell
a fucking story either.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
We went on this one double date and this
dude started telling me this story about
his son and his son's basketball game.
And I swear to God there was fucking
nothing.
There was nothing there,
you know,
usually gets a few minutes and then the
coach apparently wanted him to do dance,
but he wanted to do that and trouble.
There's not getting enough time on the
court and it's droning on and on and on
and on and on.
And the guy's just like,
no,
no sense of someone listening.
There's no sense.
There's no interaction.
It's just like he's decided that he has
a story that he likes to tell and he's
going to go on with this story and he's
using his hands and he's bending his
head forward.
He's got all this crazy movement and
there's nothing there.
Just like the cause.
Probably cause that story works in his
dad's circle,
you know,
with his other dad friends that are,
that are dads on that team.
And then,
you know,
they have kids on that team and he tells
them,
can you believe when the coach and the
other dads are like,
I'm,
I,
I saw the same thing.
I mean he usually scores so he thinks he
leaves that going.
That's a good story.
I think some people,
Joe,
that one,
they don't care.
They just wait for their time to talk.
Some people they talk and then you talk
and then they talk in the,
and everyone they know is boring and
they just can't wait to go to sleep.
And that's their life.
They fucking take sleeping pills.
Do you know how many people I've run
into that fucking takes sleeping pills
every night?
No.
Oh,
a lot.
Really.
It's one of the things that I do.
One of the things that I do,
I ask what you know,
I did this bit on Ari Shaffir show about
a house fire or a fire in a hotel that I
was in with Thompson girl.
That's right,
that's right.
And a Joey Diaz remember that fight
about it.
They tell us not to take the elevator.
We get stuck in the stay with a host
point of the story is I was ready to
fucking stampede these people cause they
were slowly walking down the stairs and
we got outside.
We were looking for Joey,
we were panicking.
Joey comes outside and they'd go,
where were you?
He goes,
I took the elevator like a doctor.
He was smoking a joint outsider and he's
smoking a joint.
He's the greatest.
But I realized while I was doing this
that some of these people were literally
waking up while they were walking.
And then I started thinking,
how many of these fucks are on sleeping
pills?
Because I knew Kevin James,
Kevin James would take sleeping pills
and he would do shit.
Like he made dinner once and he just
didn't want to admit that he made dinner
like you think.
I think he went to the store and bought
a Turkey or something crazy like that
and cooked it and went,
got up in the morning and didn't want to
admit he did it.
He was like,
no,
I didn't fucking do that because he
didn't remember it.
Didn't remember it at all cause it
warped him that much.
Remember Shit,
they just do things that don't never
taken one scary dude.
They scare the shit out of me when I'm
not tired.
I stay awake.
I'm crazy.
That's crazy.
How fucking crazy.
Yeah.
If I'm not tired I just get up and do
shit.
I'm crazy.
Now do you sleep well when you like a
brick?
You know what I do if I'm tired or if I
want to get tired,
I jerk off.
Yeah.
I go out like a baby
almost instantly.
Especially high.
Oh,
sometimes get paranoid though.
Right in the middle of jerk.
I don't know
when is it going to hit.
What if tonight's the night that I never
wake up at those.
So I started getting into pain,
uh,
sleeping pills like I started asking and
people I work with,
uh,
at the UFC,
fucking tons of them.
Tons of them take sleeping pills every
night.
Tons of them.
And I'm like,
what the fuck man?
Every night.
Yeah,
I can't sleep without him.
Oh my God.
But that's not good.
You're not started.
It seems like the key to that.
Yes.
You don't get good sleep on though.
I don't think you get real sleep.
I heard a doctor talk about that one
time,
that you're not actually getting the
benefit of real sleep on that yet.
You're shutting something down,
but you're not actually dipping into
real rem sleep and,
and,
and getting all the benefits to your
brain that you're almost like getting
knocked out unconscious.
Right.
You're like,
when you get fucked up like Michael
Jackson.
Yeah.
I mean,
he went as deep as you get.
He was taking that fucking stuff that
they used to put people under
anesthesia.
He's getting hit anesthetized.
Yeah.
He imagined that every night a doctor's
administering that.
Oh,
through a mass.
K Are we removing your gallbladder?
No,
I just want to take a nap.
So just,
I just like this thing.
Oh,
well he was probably so fucked up.
You know,
I saw Dick Gregory talking about him and
it was really interesting because Dick
Gregory was getting interviewed by this
guy and I'm,
the guy was talking to him about Michael
Jackson and Dick Gregory just started
going off and he,
and he started screaming.
He never had a fucking child.
Do you understand me?
He never had a fucking childhood.
He never bounced a ball and he's just
started going off of it.
Cause I guess he knew Michael Jackson
and was just saying he missed that part
of his childhood.
Like the whole Neverland thing and
hanging out with children.
A big part of that was just that he
never had a childhood.
I think that makes sense.
It does make sense.
I don't know if he ever did anything to
anybody.
I don't know cause I wasn't there
obviously.
But I think a lot of the people that
he's hanging around with,
those little kids,
their parents realize like this is a
fucking golden ticket.
Even if he never did anything,
they realize like,
this is a guy.
My kids spend the night over this
fucking crazy.
Multi-Multi multimillionaire's house
hoes up fucking backyard filled with
amusement park rides,
toys in his house,
like monkeys and zebras and shit.
Yes.
If he's not a pedophile,
you know,
like there's something going on.
Fucking let's sue this guy.
Fuck it.
Yeah.
Who knows?
That he's a sad,
it's a sad story when you think about,
I mean
it's pretty well documented that that it
wasn't very pleasant to be a Joe Jackson
Kid.
No,
no.
That had to be a fucking disaster.
Yeah.
Then that'd be a goddamn nightmare.
And then you sound like a crazy guy.
That's how you get good.
Having a dad make you do that dance one
more time I guess.
But it's pretty,
is that the only way I wonder?
I don't think so.
Probably the only way to get that good.
I do.
I do think with,
uh,
with athletes,
you know,
I've read a lot of stories about how
dads affect certain athletes,
some of them,
but,
but there's the other side of it that
some of them just have that focus and
that desire themselves.
And some of them say,
the only way you get this good and it's
in you,
you gotta be the one that wakes up and
goes on the run and trains and that's
how you get it.
But there's the flip side of that is the
dad,
you know,
the overbearing dad that I'm going to
make you a champion or you have,
a lot of times it was overbearing.
Dad's kid winds up rebelling.
Sure.
They wind up just abandoning that dad
and they never want to have anything to
do with,
I'm sure todd Marinovich and Mark
Marinovich,
you know that's that whole story.
Yeah.
His Dad,
Marvin Marinovich was this like
legendary strength and conditioning
coach.
He's a guy I worked with Bj Penn when Bj
Penn was in his prime and he just has
these crazy really revolutionary ideas
when it comes to strength and
conditioning.
And he had his son on this insane
organic diet and I don't think he views
even feeding them meat when he was young
and it was at home.
So it was a,
this was 24 seven it was,
you're going to,
it's not like,
here's a meal plan.
Hope you stick to it.
I'm stretching him,
feeding baby.
So crazy.
We're gone.
US flexibility now.
He did make todd pretty,
pretty fucking insanely good.
I mean,
todd was a,
was a hell of a quarterback.
Oh yeah.
But he also was freaking out and you
know,
went to drugs,
I think as a release for how,
how overbearing dad could be.
Yeah.
He blew a fuse.
There's a really interesting
documentary.
I think it's one of those espn,
it is 30 for 30 yeah.
I watched it and I was like,
wow.
Yeah.
What a,
what a weird life.
Having a dad.
Like,
then he became like a painter.
He's like an artist now.
Todd is now.
That's interesting.
He could have been,
it's worldclass NFL quarterback.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
But I think the only thing that really
derailed that was probably the drugs,
right?
Probably.
Yeah.
Well also desire.
Like he,
I guess he just didn't want to do that.
Yeah.
That's that desire thing.
Like you have to have it in you.
Like they say that some people do have
it in them and some people don't.
And so when you look at someone that
became successful,
it's so hard to figure out,
like what was it that drove that guy to
be so obsessed that he had to be the
best baseball player,
the best basketball player?
Like was it,
was it his upbringing?
Did he have,
I mean,
with everybody,
there's a
different story.
Some people,
they had still had to prove something
like maybe they were born,
uh,
you know,
single mom didn't have a father always
angry and they want to prove to the
world.
There's those guys a lot.
There's a lot of proof to dads.
You know,
Jerry West,
his story that he's the guy that's the
logo of the NBA,
you know,
the outline of the player playing is
Jerry West and he had a really abusive
dad and he even said an interview.
He didn't think he would be as driven as
good in and be a great player if he
hadn't had basically a shitty dad.
Wow.
Yeah.
So there's,
there is a lot of that or the Herschel
Walker story.
Did you see his,
what was his story?
His story was,
it wasn't anything about that.
His parents,
he had a good relationship with his was
getting bullied.
You know,
he was teased and bullied.
What the fuck could bully that guy?
I guess eight,
nine,
10 years old,
you know,
we're talking to that.
Yes.
But he was getting pushed around.
He was Chubby and then it was Lord.
It was that focus though of I'm not
going to get pushed around anymore.
I'm not,
I'm not going to get bullied.
They,
he started running and doing those
insane claims at least of pushups and
sit ups and then he just,
you know,
also had genetics.
He was freak fucking ass.
He's still a freak.
He is still a freak come back then.
And the thing about Herschel Walker is
he allegedly never lifted weights.
Yeah,
that was a big thing.
Um,
I don't know if that's true,
man.
I don't know if it's true either.
Cause a lot of people said they saw,
like I saw him lift weights like people,
I was with him in the fucking weight
room.
Like when you talk to a strength and
conditioning coaches,
they're like,
there's muscles on that guy that you
really don't develop unless you're
picking up heavy shit.
Sure.
But I don't know if that's the truth.
I don't push up.
Claims are 5,000 a day for back then.
So that's a little also,
you know,
I'm a big Herschel Fan,
but that's a lot of fucking pushups.
I can do that.
I can do that shit that easy.
He was,
he,
he's like,
I was doing it between every commercial,
you know,
watching shows.
I'll just hit the ground,
bang out like 500 pushups.
Like,
come on man.
I think there's a lot in a row.
Uh,
a lot of these maybe,
you know,
like the fake ones and kind of push up
half ones yet.
Well,
he definitely did something right.
Whatever he did.
But he also says something that he said,
some stuff that's not physically
possible.
Like he said,
he only eats a salad in a bowl of soup a
day.
Well that's not enough calories to keep
your body mass.
That doesn't make your whole body.
The only reason why your body is the
size that it is as because you take in
calories I enough to fuel all that
muscle,
right?
If you don't take in enough calories to
fuel all that muscle,
your body starts eating that muscle.
And that's a fact.
That's just physiology.
So did you wonder,
by the way,
I was listening to your uh,
Lance Armstrong episode,
how when he was talking about how
writers are just not eat and you go
like,
how do you have any energy to ride?
Yeah.
We're not talking about a leisurely
stroll down the beach.
Yeah.
You guys are training for Tour de France
and starving
yourself.
How,
how do you have the probably
amphetamines if not amphetamines,
caffeine,
some,
whatever.
Legal and it isn't there.
Just all kinds of cramping going on.
Your body's just,
I would think freaking out.
I would imagine me.
Fuck man,
I have no idea how he said that's a very
common like bike cyclists that cyclers
colors,
right?
No,
it's cyclists.
It's not cyclers.
No
fucking mad at Jesus Christ.
He got mad at me,
man.
It was like,
it's cyclists.
Cyclists don't say cycling is so funny,
but I guess it's like if someone said
the ultimate fighting challenge.
No,
it's championship championship.
You ultimate 40 challenge challenge,
you know cyclist.
Got It.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
I think there's a lot of mental
toughness involved in that sport for
sure.
I mean those fucking people are savages.
They really are.
And they really are.
Yeah.
Just to,
I mean,
how many days in a row do they do it?
I think it's 21 something insane like
that.
2125 something like that.
Fuck man.
A hundred miles a day and 2,500 miles
total.
What I know or have you heard about
these super,
the super,
I don't know the right term.
Mega Marathon.
Yeah.
The 50 mile ones and then they do them
back to back.
There's a few people that do them day
after day after day as your body just
sustained,
keep going.
In my neighborhood,
she ran to a ultra marathons in a row,
two days in a row,
100 miles one day,
and then a hundred miles the next day.
That's a chicken.
Hates her husband.
Sure.
You think fucking piece I shut.
She's fueled by anger.
You say my problems make your dicks off.
I'm going to write this 200 fucking
miles.
Exactly.
She comes home and their toenails fall
off.
Their toenails fall off when they do
that.
I saw a real sports about that
and then a guy who's so didn't care
about that just had them lasered off.
Whoa.
Because they kept falling off and he
goes,
I don't need them.
So he just had them watch.
What purpose do they serve?
The guests.
They protect the tips of your fingers.
So that was going on on a man.
It is a weird thing.
When you look at fingernails,
they are strange.
They really are this weird,
hard surface on the,
like every other animal that has nails,
their claws right there,
the design to climb things or the design
to kill.
But we have these like weird tips for
good for opening up on envelopes.
Stickers.
Yeah.
That's where we have these scraping
stickers off.
Yeah.
It's a weird feature of our bodies.
It's weird how a person developed and
not only that,
like they just keep growing.
So you're supposed to cut them.
Like if you don't cut,
you ever
seen that guy in India that grew his
nails like the world's longest nails?
Yeah,
I've seen,
I don't know if I've seen him.
I've seen photos like that's so gross.
I think he did it for more than 18 years
or something like that.
Just grew as nails and they'd grew so
long that he couldn't use his hand.
That's one of them there.
They grow like that and what's facile?
Two hands like that I'm on.
So he has to wear like special shirts
with no sleeves.
That's ridiculous.
Is I saw a dark guy.
I saw a tlc show where it was um,
I dunno.
Weird.
They have all these shows,
weird people.
And it was a lady who didn't cut her
toenails
and they,
they grow and curl,
you know,
she can't wear regular shoes and I don't
think she can work.
I think that was the other thing.
She's like,
I can't go to work.
I'm a fuck up.
These nails.
So
stupid.
I got priorities.
Yeah.
That lady was weird.
She,
she kept him straight.
Oh,
Jesus.
No,
thank you.
Good Lord.
That's like a bear.
She looks like a bear.
Well,
how stranger people,
I don't know.
I'm sexy,
but you have to take care of those nails
like,
oh,
what's on the left?
No lower left.
Look at that.
What are those?
Oh God.
Well that seems like we were looking at
some other stuff.
They're like,
we're looking at hand nails and toenails
there because there's the toenails and
then nails coming down.
It's coming down.
Yeah.
Christ.
Yeah,
some disgusting about long nails.
Yeah.
Y Yeah.
Even sometimes women will have the
slightly longer pedicure.
Why do you have long?
Well,
I don't even understand why.
Yeah.
Even slightly longer term growth trend.
Get that shit.
Even man,
you hate for that.
You have a half inch long on your toes
like,
Ooh,
so gross.
He fucking Weirdo.
Why are you doing that?
What are you using them for?
It isn't that strange though because of
a half inch on your fingers is totally
acceptable and can even be sexy.
Right?
Like girls would like red nails.
Sure.
Kind of sexy,
right?
Why is that?
I don't know the color.
I just,
because of the color,
but well,
how come the red toenails that are a
little long,
I'm not sexy maybe to somebody that it
is.
I'm saying I think it's fucking foul.
Somebody,
I'm sure someone's going to be,
I love those half luggage,
toenails,
Grossman who wants toenails that go over
the edge and inch people do it
purposely.
So they have to be,
have to be doing it.
Now.
Maybe it's one of those things like
girls think guys like it,
but only girls like it.
Like really skinny girls.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You know,
like girls will see a girl that's like
basically dying and he's like,
oh,
she's hot.
Yeah.
Look how skinny Shannon.
She's.
Yeah.
Miss,
how's that skinny?
No,
you don't.
There's some people that really think
that that looks good.
They really do because of a fashion
models,
you know?
Um,
I just don't,
I don't understand that.
Like,
no guy likes that.
I don't think so.
He was something,
it must be a few guys,
but they're fucked up.
Yeah.
But normal guys want meat.
Something to grab onto.
Yeah.
It's normal.
Like every guy I've ever asked,
would you rather your girl be 15 pounds
too heavy or 15 pounds to light?
Everybody says too heavy.
Everyone for sure to light is like,
like you gotta be okay.
Well yeah,
of course you're,
you're dying.
Yeah.
You're tired all the time.
You face is all sucked in.
Like you're making weight for a fight.
He to the right to take the ass moving.
Juggling jiggles are good.
Yes.
Bank.
That's what I'm talking about.
I'm saying.
So tell me about throat zillow.
So I started this podcast before we
started.
He started telling me to start.
I go,
stop save it.
I you asked me if I have on snapchat.
Yes.
And I said,
no,
I don't post on snapchat.
And I said,
well,
I do have a snapchat account just to
follow throat zillow.
And you said WHO's that?
And wait,
here's the whole story.
So my buddy josh potter is really,
he's a great comic out of Buffalo.
He turned me onto this.
Um,
so snapchat for people that don't know,
you know,
you post,
you can post photos but also like videos
15,
I think they're 15 seconds and they time
out and then once they air they're gone.
You know.
So if you follow someone and they post
all the time,
you,
you're seeing essentially a timeline of
their day or week.
So throw zillow came to prominence
because she is a,
uh,
an escort in the Dallas area and she's
hooked up with a number of high profile
people who she doesn't call out,
but one of them,
um,
Dallas Cowboy,
offensive Lineman,
Lael Collins hired her to blow him and
eat his ass and she did it,
but then he didn't pay her.
So she put him on blast,
called them out,
told media outlets and uh,
then I got turned onto her,
her snapchat because she'll also post
sometimes little snaps of her blowing
guys and eating their asses.
And I'm also running out of gas.
She does no,
don't put that way.
I don't think she wants that went up.
Why?
Because that doesn't actually post her
face.
Oh yeah.
I don't know.
I mean that actually her,
I don't know if that's her.
I've never actually seen her face.
Um,
but anyways,
she,
uh,
she really has a gift.
She's awesome.
She goes,
she had a monster energy Canada or mouth
man.
You should see her.
What with with Dixon?
Her mouth.
It's a,
she also goes by orally gifted.
Um,
two one four,
which I think is the dallas,
but yeah,
there it is.
Or the gifted underscore two and four.
She,
uh,
it says I swallow everything.
Lol.
And what does that line and they know,
oh,
what does that alarm or something,
I don't know.
That might be the end of a guy's cock
that she sucked off
the old stick.
Yeah.
But she posts hilarious stuff,
you know?
Yeah.
And she'll,
she'll do things like,
um,
don't,
nobody went to Dick suck right now.
Somebody is going to get something to
eat that and be like this.
She's like,
I just feel like giving me head right
and have it,
nobody's hitting me up.
I'm going to go get some gas.
And then she'll get some gas orally
gifted.
Well,
there was that other girl that got
famous in the hip hop world.
She called herself superhead.
That's right.
Yeah,
I remember that.
I know you're aware of,
well this,
yeah,
she was a tomboy.
She did a bunch of music videos too.
She was in,
she was a video vixen.
Oh,
and she was,
yeah,
she was blowing everyone left and right.
I think she wrote a book about it.
Yeah.
But I might own actually own it.
Well she's,
she puts everybody on blast.
Like Bobby Brown came over her house and
fell asleep on her couch and she,
she filmed it.
That's fucked up though,
right?
I think.
I think the fucked up thing like I,
so I had throat Zyl on my podcasts.
I did.
Yeah.
I messaged her and she called in,
so she,
she,
she called into the show and that's
hilarious.
And she was really candid and really
funny.
And she basically said,
you know,
I provide this service,
people pay and you know,
I'd never would call you out there.
That's part of the sort of unspoken
deal.
Right.
But when this guy didn't pay up,
it was fucked up.
You know,
we agreed to something and he goes,
oh,
I only have 100 bucks on me.
Rude.
Yeah.
So she goes at that point,
that's when I,
you know,
called him out.
Yeah.
Well he treated her like an idiot.
Yeah,
exactly.
Which was the wrong thing to do.
What a rude guy eat someone's ass.
And then we actually,
Josh and I had this car and I know you
don't call a football,
but maybe you'll be able to weigh in on
this.
We,
we started to discuss which position
players have the worst assholes because
if,
uh,
she ate a pretty big guys ass.
I mean,
how big is e six six,
three 30.
That's a big guy.
It's a big guy.
And she said it was a lot of work to get
in there,
you know.
So she said,
she said with skinny guys,
she can,
you know,
put them in the,
change my diaper,
like pull their,
pushing their legs up and get underneath
there.
But with these big guys,
the big guys,
they got to lay on their stomach.
And then you got to kind of open their
asshole out.
Does she require that they go through
some sort of a cleansing procedure?
I asked.
I'm glad you brought that up and she
said that no one's ever not been ready
for it.
In other words,
cleaned up,
trimmed up everyone.
Everyone's ready to go.
No one's,
no one has to be sent to,
but well,
she is known for her work.
So
yeah,
these guys fired their proper work
environment.
I think so.
Yeah.
You,
you will.
You wouldn't ask someone to do
electrical work in the pouring rain.
Exactly.
That makes sense.
A great analogy actually.
Yes.
So she's um,
she says,
you know,
it's,
it's one of her go to moves and gas.
Yeah.
I have a buddy of mine who hooked up
with this girl.
Yeah.
And uh,
they went back and forth online and then
they got together and he said
immediately before she even blew him,
she went right to his ass and I went,
what?
And he goes,
yeah.
He goes,
I just got off a plane.
Fucking disgusting.
Travel as is bad.
I'm like,
why?
He goes,
I was so disgusted.
I've never called her again.
She went right to his ass.
I'm like,
who does that?
A friend of mine said he also had an
online hookup where the lady was,
you know,
pretty,
aggressive with how she was setting it
up and he goes,
come on over.
And he said it was her first one.
He goes,
I wasn't prepared for that.
I had never went to the,
went to the like,
you know,
some ladies are bold.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's a weird move though,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Go straight to the butthole.
Straight to the,
what do you,
what kind of message you're trying to
send?
It's trying to say like,
this is going to go crazy.
I'm going nuts.
You're saying I'm freaky.
Like if you were,
if you were wondering,
I am.
That's what you're saying.
As freaky as is possible.
That's just,
you bring a bunch of friends over to
lick his ass too.
That's yet
whistle.
And a bunch of girls start knocking on
the door like PAC man knoweth all have
fucking lobster bibs on.
Yeah.
That's pretty good.
You're saying I'm advanced.
Yeah.
I'm just does it,
you're not married me.
It's true.
Maybe that's why.
Maybe that's why she did it.
Maybe she just doesn't want a commitment
shaped the best way to keep a guy from
wanting to marry you.
It was just make them disgusted.
Eat His asshole right away.
Just really just tongue.
Fuck it.
You're not even like coaxing her into it
or anything.
She just leaves with that just pushed my
friend said he just,
uh,
he thought she was going to blow him and
she grabbed his dick,
picked it up and then pushed his legs
forward and he was like,
what?
She's just gobble,
gobble,
like a rottweiler drinking out of a
toilet bowl.
Some chicks are just cool man.
Yeah man.
She's the best.
Well,
I mean how many guys are told their
friends that kind of a story and they're
like,
wow,
that's awesome.
Awesome.
So what you guys doing next?
So you found a good girl,
Huh?
Being the family this weekend,
trying to get her pregnant,
bro.
Oh my God.
Oh,
you don't want to do that Wolf Wolf
Wharf.
[inaudible].
Yeah.
That's a weird Dang shit comes out of
there.
Like why?
Yeah.
Hmm.
Well why does it feel good though?
I know that's also part of the problem.
Why doesn't your asshole feel like your
fingernails?
Well,
hasn't it just like something that dead
dull spot that just pumps out shit.
Yeah.
I remember doing that to someone in
college.
I only did it cause I saw it in a movie,
you know?
You know what I did?
I got Hershey's Syrup and I thought it
was like Kinky to do it.
And then I realized as the Hershey
Spirit Spirit,
it just looks like she shit all over
because it's just liquid chocolate.
So I pulled my face up and I'm like,
Oh man,
it looks like she just shit in my mouth
even though it didn't taste like it.
Sure.
Looked like it.
Yeah.
That's not a good look.
No.
Yeah.
Look,
yeah,
it's like cherry sauce.
Put Cherry sauce all over.
Yeah.
That's not good.
I don't think she liked it either.
No.
Did she get weirded out by,
you know,
she just like,
but you want to do right.
Alrighty.
Alright man.
Did she say it felt good?
Uh,
I don't remember actually.
I mean,
I don't,
I know,
I didn't think she was like,
hey,
this sucks,
but whatever.
I don't remember
being,
you know,
big applause,
break or anything.
It's weird that some girls don't want to
have nothing to do with taking the ass
where other girls beg for it.
Yeah.
They love it.
Put something in there.
All Right,
God,
Huh?
Yeah,
but girls with toys,
that's always weird.
Hold on a second.
And girls come back with like a giant
black rubber Dick.
Like,
hey,
hey.
Now where's this going?
That's for you,
right?
Or girl with a strap on.
Ooh,
I never had that.
No,
not interested.
Hmm.
Yeah.
If I want it done,
I'd fuck dudes.
Right.
Or have dudes fuck me.
Why?
Why would I want a girl to pretend to be
a dude?
Unless you love it.
Well,
some people like really trainees,
you know?
Yeah.
Insensitive.
I was insensitive with that word.
Yeah.
You still say cabbies though.
I don't have to take shabby call cabby
point counterpoint.
Well,
he sounds cute to me.
It does sound kind of,
I don't know why it's bad.
It's,
it's,
it's offensive.
What do you think,
I mean,
is it pretty obvious that the attraction
there for the people that are attracted
to it is that it's looks like something
and it's not,
I mean,
is that the appeal you think?
Um,
I think people that like transgender
guys,
I mean there's probably a whole fucking
spectrum of different things that people
like them,
why they like it,
right.
But I think some of them,
they like the idea of it being like
naughty,
like someone with like she's got tits
and she's got a beautiful face and then
you take her.
Right.
It's
just exciting that it's crazy.
Not t what also could be that you had
some weird experience during your
formative period,
like when you were young,
like,
like when you're developing,
apparently they say,
Chris Ryan has described this to me,
um,
that there's a state doctor,
Chris Ryan who wrote that book sex at
dawn.
I do podcasts with them all the time.
And he was talking about imprinting,
like as you're young,
like during your formative years,
I think it's,
I think he said between somewhere
between like 11 and 13 are nine and 13
or something like that,
that something can happen sexually.
Like someone could do something to use.
Actually,
maybe a man can do something nice
actually.
And you might not even be gay,
but you might get like sexually
imprinted,
you know,
that like that somehow or another
excites you and some sort of a weird way
even reluctantly excites you.
Yeah.
Even reluctantly.
Well,
for a lot of people there,
they're afraid of the shame that comes
with liking what you like.
Sure.
Like if you're a supposedly heterosexual
man,
but you're really into transgender
women,
there's,
you know,
you could run a risk of people finding
out at work and,
and thinking you're fucked up and um,
or you know,
labeling you so deviant and thinking
like,
what else is this fucker into?
You know,
it's weird.
I know,
I know.
Almost weirder than being gay because
if,
I mean there's some people that don't
like gay people.
There's some people are afraid of it or
there's a religious thing,
you know?
But I think that that's more accepted.
Maybe even then wanting to date a
transgender person.
Oh,
for sure.
I mean,
even in today's world,
the,
I think a lot of people have come along
way with,
you know,
at least somewhat accepting
homosexuality.
But when you get to transgender,
that's a big leap for a lot of people.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
Right?
I think,
I think so.
I don't know.
Yeah.
They start looking at like you like this
is what your cards are.
You got to fucking deal with it.
You gotta take it.
Yeah.
And then some people like,
but my,
I got the wrong cards.
[inaudible] I got out there.
I feel like inside I got the wrong
cards.
Sure.
Not only do I support that,
I support people that feel like a dude,
but want to be a girl.
Like I was definitely born a guy.
I'm a guy,
but ah,
I don't want to be a girl.
Yeah.
Fuck it.
I want to get a sex change.
Okay.
I don't give a shit.
Yeah,
I'm gay.
I don't care if you tattoo your face,
go for it.
I had never care
what turns somebody on,
you know what I mean?
Like I don't understand how it would
bother you when when some people are
afraid,
you know you're seeing like the shame
and people finding out.
But it's amazing to me that it would
bother somebody.
What gets somebody else off?
You know?
I think its Americans,
Puritan culture where we're apparently
when you compare us to the rest of the
world,
like as far as like what,
what we like and do you know what we'll
accept from society,
from people were like one of the most
puritan cultures on the planet.
So bizarre to think that that's our,
our surroundings.
Because you're,
when you're in it,
you don't even think about until you
step out and you see how,
you know other cultures are.
Do you think we make the most porn if
you like the yeah,
I bet we make the most,
I think without question we make the
most without question.
Without question.
Yeah.
Because industrywide I'm talking just as
a business,
there's,
there's no other place that's creating
the amount of content as the San
Fernando Valley.
It's gotta be,
well,
they're fucked now because they have to
wear condoms.
Stats.
That's why there'll be a change,
a shift,
but for the last 30 years,
it's gotta be California.
It's like when they started shipping
jobs overseas,
that's what it is.
God dammit fucking manufacturing jobs.
The fuck the middleclass.
It's harder than that to porn.
Shipping all these hard Dick's to her
place needs someone to put this
somewhere.
I put them wrapping them up with
rubbers.
That's the thing.
The idea.
That is a bummer,
by the way,
to me to watch that.
I've seen that and like,
I don't want to watch a guy wearing a
rubber.
No,
it's,
Oh,
isn't that funny?
Like why would you care?
But there's something about like,
they even try to trick you by having
those like super transparent rubbers.
Yes.
But there's something about the
glistening of the Dick just doesn't look
realistic.
You can't see the end like the rim that
might've went down.
You know,
that's a fucking rubber robberies dicks
off though.
You know,
it bums me out the most when a girl's
blown a guy with a rubber on just stop.
Stop Buddy.
Just jerk off on the top of her head and
that'd be better.
I'll tell you don't even come near her
face.
Don't let her blow you the eye.
I just don't like it.
I don't want to watch it.
I don't want to see it.
I've seen one of those blooper videos
where they has the guy like,
it's like a double team and one guy
finishes on a girl's head,
you know,
on her hair and she goes,
did you just come in my hair and the
whole scene to stops and there's like a
big fight.
Everyone's screaming and yelling.
Really?
Yeah,
it's,
and he was like,
I'm sorry.
She got mad.
Oh really mad.
Really Mad.
Yeah.
Why don't you get mad at that?
Because he went right into her hair and
so she can't clean it.
I don't know.
I mean he's planning on going out like,
I think she had an appointment
afterwards.
Yeah.
Get their hair did and when they get
their hair,
did they like,
they like to keep it that way for days.
Do not fuck with the hair.
Yeah.
Don't come in it for sure.
Well,
especially if there's like hairspray and
then it becomes like stalagmites hangs
down,
gets caught up in the fucking webbing of
the hair.
No,
no,
wait.
Oh Man.
Not Bueno.
Even slightly.
No,
no.
It's the worst.
But eyelashes are okay.
Come on the eyelashes.
Yeah.
When they get it in the mug and then
it's dripping off their eyelashes like
Ooh,
they have that look on their face and
the flood or the IIF letter.
The eyelashes kind of in some ways
protect them from com.
Like a good,
that's why we have eyelashes.
Didn't Dr. Ryan talk about that?
A good thick shield like palm fronds?
Yeah.
Who Tags,
you know,
you know Joe,
we've studied,
um,
for the last few hundred thousand years.
Humans have eyelashes to protect them
from facials.
There's a weird thing,
huh?
Facials?
Like what?
Where'd that come from?
Like why,
why common someone's face?
Like what,
like come it used to,
it's kind of power.
It's a power move,
right?
That I think it's a power move.
What's a freak move to right?
True girl sticks her tongue out.
She goes,
ah,
how about the scoop and score?
Isn't that crazy?
That's disgusting.
It's like,
oh,
there's little up here.
And they take it down and then they
pretend that it's the most delicious
thing ever.
That even on your watch and you're like,
I don't know,
it's been sitting on your face for a
while.
You didn't remember it was there.
It's kind of cooled off and you're like,
it's delicious.
I like hot jar.
It's like,
you know,
you never eat a pot pie when it's cold.
Well don't you think those,
those save all the just videos
trusting man.
They see that's where a fellow draws the
line.
Like if you date a girl,
she used to be a porn star.
Well you know she just having sex.
Who cares if it's on camera?
But then if you watch a video of like
five guys coming into a mug and she just
chugs it as,
so there's a lot of those out there.
Jamie is going to throw up
and they like drinking through a straw.
So Gross,
Mad Max Hardcore Guy.
He opened up a woman's asshole.
Well,
the speculum,
then he pissed inside of it and then
attached to a straw to it and made her
drink is pissed.
That was opened up like a bowl.
What do you think his imprinting is from
childhood?
Whatever it is.
Not Crazy.
Not Good.
Someone did bad things.
I saw one of those,
uh,
was is a speculum,
is that what it's called when they open
you up and the girl's ass and then they
put cereal and milk and somebody say to
that of their fucking groceries shit
too.
That's when they need to stop.
Like,
I've had that.
I've had this bit,
uh,
for a while.
Then I just never figured out what to do
with onstage.
But the bit was like,
why are they still making porn?
Ou has jerked off to all the porn.
Like,
how could anybody who's,
who's showing up at the video store on
Monday morning going,
Shit,
new shit here.
It wasn't new shit.
Fucking constantly checking like no one
has seen all of them.
Like we've,
there's enough,
there's,
you could jerk off once an hour,
every hour for the rest of your life and
you would never get through all the porn
that's ever been made through 10
lifetimes.
You could do that,
but yet they're still making it.
Sure.
Like what is that?
I Dunno.
There's
just this insatiable appetite for it,
I guess from enough people because it's
not like music or comedy or something
where people want new things because you
like,
well,
maybe it is.
Maybe that's it.
I was going to say you like a particular
artist might say,
uh,
you know Chris Rock.
Like when's Chris rock or Tom Segura
who's got a new netflix special that's
available this Friday,
this Friday.
That's right.
Shameless plug.
Um,
so like if you're a thompson guerra fan,
like there's only one way to get it.
You've got to wait for Tom Segura to put
out a new CD or a new,
a new,
a Netflix special.
But for a porn,
I guess maybe that's what it is.
I mean guys like jacking off to one
girl.
Right?
So they're like,
they become like a Kendra lust fan.
Sure.
You ever seen her?
I that,
that name sounds familiar.
So I'm sure I have all this good woman.
She's all woman.
All she's milfy too.
She looks like she's like in her late
thirties and it's ready to party.
I'm talking about it has some experience
but keeps taking takes care of herself.
Sure,
yeah.
Yeah.
So like if you're a fan of hers,
there's only one way to get it.
You got to watch her videos.
You know what mean?
There she goes,
Pam.
Oh yeah,
no,
she,
that was sure
somebody gets hurt.
So like if you're a fan of any,
you know,
fill in the blank,
Tara,
Patrick,
whatever.
You got to wait for her,
which she's retired.
He had to wait for it.
That's bomber.
When girls are still hot and they
retire,
what are you doing?
Well still jerking off over here.
Yeah,
you're not done.
And I'm done.
You know,
it's like back or not.
Yeah.
It's like,
uh,
you know if Connor Mcgregor retires now
like come on,
come on.
You got a few good years left in at
least cause you make a few videos.
There's a thing about watching them,
you know where guys get obsessed with
like one girl and then they'll go to
like the avn shows and then wait in line
to get a picture signed and a,
that's too far.
Almost they're going to charge how far
over truck I got a photo of a true and
they're like,
they're holding onto her and if the
girls do escorting,
yes.
The other thing,
some of those porn stars like you can
actually fuck them.
Yeah.
I'm sure it's a pretty penny though,
right?
A couple of grand?
Probably think so.
Yeah.
But is that awful?
I mean,
is that worse?
Here's the question.
Here's the big question.
Is that worse?
Easy over there.
You're right.
Getting sick.
None of news.
Um,
is it worse to have sex with a guy who's
paying you than it is to have sex with a
guy on film?
Is there a line that's crossed that?
Mm hmm.
What do you mean by worse though?
Well,
I don't give a fuck either way,
but for some people is the perception
more so like is it worse to be a girl it
was a porn star who also escorts or is
it,
is it,
you know what's absolutely,
I think the,
it's between the two.
I would do it off camera.
So you're,
it's not documented unless you,
unless for some reason you want it to be
documented,
you know,
if you're doing just your escorting,
well it's just between you and whoever
you do it with.
So you don't have that social stigma of
being known for doing that.
Right.
But,
but for those girls,
they don't care about that social
stigma.
I got you.
I mean,
that's their living.
Sure.
But is it worse?
Is it worse to be an escort and a porn
star or just a porn star?
Or is it a stupid question?
Oh no,
man.
I mean,
it might be a stupid question.
I just feel like they're probably trying
to get lucrative.
That's exactly what it is.
So just keep taking those escorts.
Hires.
That's exactly it is.
Yeah.
Well it's a good move for them for sure.
Probably get,
I bet some of them get paid.
A lot of them I've had the rich dudes
yeah.
Which cause they look,
um,
and then if she was like,
it's 10,000 and for the guy who was
like,
okay,
yeah,
then you,
you're getting paid man.
Yeah.
Well Red Ban had something and he put on
twitter the other day about a girls that
uh,
take another vacation to go shopping and
do by,
you know,
like,
and like he knows it was a thinly veiled
prostitution reference.
Uh Huh.
Cause that's what a lot of people do
apparently.
Oh really?
They go,
I'm going shopping.
Well there's so much money in Dubai.
Yeah.
So much money.
Like,
you can't even have your been,
I've never been,
I was there once for the UFC because a,
there was a ufc in Abu Dhabi and we went
to Dubai to do the Wayans,
the Wayans and Dubai and then we drove
to a Abu Dhabi from there.
Like fucking when you drive you have to
drive the fucking speed limit are,
they will hit you with a missile,
they'll shoot you in the face with a
missile.
Like it's so strict.
They're like the drivers,
like they will not violate the speed
limit.
Like if you violate the speed limit,
if you do anything wrong,
anything that can allow you to get
locked up,
who knows what the fuck's going to
happen to the office.
Literally,
who knows what's going to happen.
Especially if you are in a position like
a driver or a service person,
like a waiter or waitress or a bartender
or something that you cannot fuck around
over there.
Like it is not,
America is,
you're essentially dealing with kings.
Like it's some kind of game of thrones
type shit and a lot of ways.
But,
um,
so we were there.
And,
uh,
when you're in Dubai,
every fucking car you see is,
you know,
hundred thousand dollars,
$200,000.
So it's all Mercedes and Ferrari's and
Lamborghini's.
It's like everywhere.
I mean it's literally,
it's like,
like a joke.
It was like a scene in a movie of
extreme opulence,
like over the top opulence.
When you go,
come on,
it's not really like that,
but it is really like that.
Like everywhere you go,
everyone's got a million dollar car and
there's Bugatti va,
Ron's,
they've got like one point $5 million.
It's insane.
It's crazy.
The amount of wealth.
I remember that the,
uh,
Mike,
one of my cousins
came to do English course here at USC
and he has people from all different
countries.
And so the,
the Abu Dhabi guys,
uh,
took the classes,
the kids from the class,
you know,
we've taught kids,
I'm saying 22 year old people,
um,
out on la.
And they would just pull out stacks of
money.
And he was,
he was like,
where'd you get that?
And he's like,
oh,
we just,
the government gave us money because
we're,
we're educating ourselves and coming
back so they'll pay for everything.
And he said,
you know,
you could go,
if you're a born there,
you can go to the government and be
like,
I need money for this.
And they would just give you that.
Yeah.
And he was just,
they were just spending on everyone's
stacks of money.
Well,
you're not supposed to drink there
either,
but you can't drink in the bars.
There's certain bars where they allow it
because Americans western picture.
But I got as a whole,
like they don't want drinking.
Hmm.
It's very strange.
And I had some friends when we were at
the UFC,
uh,
I stayed in Abu Dhabi,
but a bunch of the guys were bored and
they were like,
oh,
we're going to go to Dubai and see
what's up.
They went to a bar and they said it was
90% prostitutes.
It was all like eastern bloc
prostitutes.
Like you walked in,
it was like a wolf den and just a bunch
of wolves
looking at fucking snack on you.
[inaudible] like everywhere they went,
like just,
these girls just go there and they just
wait for someone who's got a lot of
money.
He goes,
you'll,
you'll come with me.
Let's go.
Yeah.
And then they leave with a stack.
Fat Stacks.
Yeah.
Well,
if you're a girl and you want to involve
yourself,
it's a prostitution.
It's probably a good move.
You go over there,
just clean up for a month or a week,
come back with half a year's worth of
salary.
So people aren't doing that though.
Yeah.
According to Red van allegedly.
How's he so it on this?
He knows things.
He knows.
He knows these people.
He's aware.
He knows that Hoe and mentality.
He's around hose and definitely knows
hos.
Yeah,
he knows him.
We always teased because you know,
we started doing our podcast with him
and he's our retarded stepchild.
He has special knowledge.
Yeah.
He got,
he knows things about certain things.
It's just like he's got to figure out
like he started doing his own podcast
was guys only thing first.
First episode just launched last week
and I've been telling them to do that
forever.
I'm like,
it'd be so good for you because you have
this,
you have this weird style,
this weird way about you.
I'm like,
get into it.
Yeah.
You know,
you'll find people that are wanting that
wanting to see it,
but right now they only see it if you're
on someone else's show.
Sure.
You know,
and like do your own show and it could
be all your freakiness.
Yeah.
And then I think also when you do your
own show too,
you realize like how much is involved in
like managing the sure.
Like
making sure it steers in the right
direction.
Thinking about what the subject you're
talking about.
Is this entertaining is when do I pick
this up?
Do I,
how do I ramp it up?
How do I,
how do I add some new stuff in there?
And he has a lot of expense.
I mean,
you know,
we actually,
we love,
right Ben.
Uh,
but he,
he steered our ship for a while,
you know,
kind of help shape things.
So I did a lot of people.
Imagine if all the people that started
podcasts with him could tolerate him and
stay
Ari Dunkin.
Joey is grime callen Sam.
Yeah.
Sam Aaa.
Yeah,
it,
Sam's still doing a show.
I thought.
I Dunno,
but I didn't think he'd stopped.
I don't,
I haven't seen it or heard it.
I Dunno.
Well those guys definitely still do
their,
their punch drunk,
their sports ones.
Yes.
That's still a thing.
He still does that.
They do that on a another network.
Right.
What does that all things?
Comedies.
I don't know.
All things.
Comedy.
That does sounds like in all things.
Comedy show.
Yeah.
All things.
Comedy is a lot of good shows on it,
right?
It does.
Yeah,
it does.
I mean,
that's magical and burr and then,
I mean we're,
we're part of that.
Are you in your mom's house is,
yeah.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
you know,
that being a part of all things,
comedy is almost like being part of a
collective support thing where
everybody's still owns their own shows,
but you just kind of have more power in
numbers thing,
you know?
How does that work?
Well,
I mean I think the idea behind it was
that if,
if we are all together and we can
approach people as here's what,
what,
doing business with all things comedy
means,
it means you're getting this bundle as
opposed to just saying one thing.
You still get to be your own entity,
but you're a part of something when you
need to be.
Right.
And it helps for,
it's,
it's great for promotion to,
you know,
if,
uh,
like my special comes out,
so I sent out a message to our group and
then everybody who has a podcast,
we'll get
info about helping to plug my thing for
each other.
So that's cool.
I mean,
you're getting,
if you get every show together,
you're getting a few million downloads.
Well we kind of all do that for each
other we knew anyways.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I'm always tweeting for friends and
you'd do the same and we all do that for
each other.
We support each other.
That's the best kind of network,
right?
That kind of net worth is totally
organic.
Yes.
There's no financial gain in it at all.
We all just kind of help each other.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean we,
I mean,
I know we've,
as all things comedy,
we've also worked with sponsors that,
you know,
the idea was that we're approaching you
because we have this collective and they
responded to it.
So,
okay.
So like a,
they handled the ads and they bring them
to you.
Is that how it works?
Yeah,
like so with like,
you know,
our bill approach,
um,
you know,
whatever company and say we have 50
shows,
here's our gross amount of downloads.
If you sign up to do this set amount and
then kind of divvied up amongst the
people that can do it.
So we've that a few times.
That's
interesting.
So is the amount of money that you get
based on the amount of downloads that
you have?
Yes,
exactly.
Hmm.
Who manages all that?
It seems like it's,
it's a,
it's a lot of work,
man.
I mean,
Mike is one of the guys over there.
I think Flynn,
and I'm trying to remember another name,
but it's,
it's a,
it's a job that's a full time job.
At a certain point in time though,
is you're podcast becomes more and more
successful.
It seems like that would kind of get in
the way.
Well,
it doesn't really,
like I said,
because those guys are so about Al and
bill,
Hey,
we're not taking anything from you and
do whatever you do,
whatever you want.
Right.
That they're not,
they're not saying if you do this,
you can't do that there.
It's almost like they're saying,
do whatever you do and in addition you
can do this with us.
You know?
That's a perfect world though.
It is a perfect world.
Yeah.
That's beautiful.
Your podcasts is fucking blown up,
man.
It's amazing.
It's been going well.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
And you guys do live ones too.
The live ones.
I see.
When you guys tweet about live once and
the people go to them.
It's a thing like there's a,
there's a whole thing going on with the
mommies.
Yeah.
People keep,
people get excited and they go live
podcasts or something fucking different
man.
It's fun man.
We did a at the ice house in the,
in the main room and it sold out like a
couple of months ago because we've been,
you know,
when you're doing it again,
I don't have,
uh,
we don't have it set up,
but we need to do it.
Let me gum.
I want to be a gas.
Do you want to be a guest on live?
Okay.
All right.
We're got to start doing live podcast.
I've done a few other people's podcasts
live,
but it's really fun to do live.
I did fit simmons the other day.
We had a great time.
He's doing it in the belly room.
His 500th episode with his Buddy Mike.
It was awesome.
It's really fun.
Yeah.
We uh,
we just did his show to Fitzsimmons.
You find yourself like going for jokes,
more like going,
it changes.
But here's the thing there.
So geeked up for those laughs.
Yes.
So it's a,
it becomes a really fun environment to
do it.
Then I watched another podcast live
that's not mine and not yours and not
fit semans into,
oh my God,
I wanted to run through a fucking wall.
I was like this.
Some podcasts are weird,
man.
It's,
they find their own level,
like water seeks its own level.
They find their own vibe and there's
some podcasts where you,
you go and you'll,
there's fans of that podcast.
You'd go and see it and you're like,
this is not my fucking scene
at all.
They weren't swearing.
They were doing it very much like a
radio show.
There's gotta be a bit,
a little bit of that too,
don't you think to probably stand up
shows.
Oh yeah.
You Fuck,
you don't end up walking into,
but if you were to go to,
oh,
so and so's here tonight and it's sold
out and you walk in,
you're like,
what the fuck is this?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Well that's just the way of the world,
right?
That's how it is with music,
with everything.
Movies.
I mean,
I,
I've you seen pitch perfect.
That's the singing one.
Exactly.
No,
you haven't.
no.
But fucking millions of chicks have as a
blanket pitch.
They fucking love it.
They get crazy.
It's not bad.
It's not them.
It's the,
what's the like what they like,
there's a lot of shit I like the people
don't like,
yeah.
Somebody told me one time and it was
about,
you know,
a movie come out.
It's one of those,
uh,
comedy comes out and you go,
well,
this looks like fucking shit.
Right?
And there's billboards and there's
always a few famous people in it.
And you got,
and I was hating on how shitty it
looked.
Terrible.
And he goes,
well,
you know,
this wasn't made for you.
And I go,
yeah,
no,
I know.
He goes,
no,
no.
But like there's a,
there's a lot of people that love this.
Oh yeah,
this just isn't for,
you know,
it's not made for you.
And I started to think of entertainment
differently from the moment that was
said to me that I see things now,
trailers,
posters,
commercials for something.
And I go,
oh,
but this has made for a different
audience.
You know,
there's things that are made for me
where I respond to and I go,
oh,
I fucking can't.
Well,
that's for me.
That's why it's so important to do what
you like on stage.
Oh,
stand up wise.
If you start trying to make it for
somebody.
Yeah.
Those guys are,
they're fucked.
Those guys who create those squeaky
clean acts,
but they're not squeaky clean.
Those are tortured people of course,
because they're literally making art
that's not for them.
Right.
But you're,
you,
you're,
you and you can't be,
you like the audience won't accept it.
She kept talking about roofing chicks
and sticking around and when they're
asleep.
Yeah.
I watched,
uh,
speaking to bill cosby,
I watched his lawyer,
uh,
debate some commentator or some
television pundit or whatever you would
call them hosts.
And,
uh,
she was explaining,
you know,
what,
that,
how ridiculous these allegations are and
how Mr Cosby,
you know,
didn't do any of these things and that
all these women,
like their stories,
some of them are just,
they were like,
he grabbed them by the wrist hard.
Like some of them aren't even sexual
allegations and she's like effectively
sort of muddying the water and that he
is a very rich,
wealthy man.
And then that has to be taken into
consideration that these people are
doing this for attention.
And I was like,
wow,
this is,
it's fascinating to watch the spin,
the dance,
you know?
And the guy was saying,
well,
there's 50 people though.
Right?
And she was like,
well,
out of those 50,
a lot of them are not even sexual
allegations and not even sexual assault
allegations,
which I didn't know,
you know,
only 23 or six 37.
Yeah,
I don't,
uh,
I don't know if he did or not,
but I haven't heard of another person
ever that's had 50 people claimed that
he raped them by giving them drugs.
I know it's the,
it's the,
I think the sad part is the people who
really want to defend the,
like the conspiracy theories on it.
Oh yeah.
He was,
you know,
he was about to buy NBC.
I don't know if you know that he was
making a move to by NBC and they don't
want a black man in power like that.
It's so ridiculous.
Yeah.
Oh,
they
don't.
Okay.
Nobody wants to take down cosby.
Nobody's agenda.
Was that why they would have taken down
Oprah first?
For sure.
Man.
It's so silly.
It's worth more than anyone ever.
She's the most successful entertainer
ever.
And she doesn't even have a talent.
Not a singer,
not dancer.
It's not great actress.
What?
What'd she do?
She doesn't tell jokes.
What she does.
She talks to people giving away cars,
will get up in the morning and look at
the sun and think,
eh.
It's like,
yeah.
Okay.
Well she has like positive messages.
Super Positive.
She is really good for menopausal women.
Like they really relate to her.
Oh,
a strange way.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
we're vibe down,
but I get why people do have their,
why they want to defend them.
I understand the,
the motivation and the,
and,
and feeling like,
oh yeah.
The adoration for him and wanting to
defend.
I totally get why they do it.
And the reality is we don't know.
Yeah,
that's true.
Really don't know.
But I mean,
the idea that you could never find 50
liars,
of course you could.
Of course you could.
But it's,
you know,
I think the,
the,
the argument that I find the most sort
of ignorant and uninformed is the one
where people go,
why did they wait that long?
Well,
you know,
if you,
if you talk to any sex crimes unit,
uh,
officer detective,
any psychologist about victims of sexual
assault,
it's not unusual for it to go and report
it or for it to go a long time without
someone wanting to talk about it.
It's completely within the spectrum of
normal responses to something like that.
So when people are like,
well,
you know what happened 25 years ago?
Yeah,
it's normal.
It's normal for someone not to bring it
up completely normal.
Well,
there's a lot of shame involved.
Of course.
Some women,
they would rather just forget about it
then report it.
Yeah.
They would rather just pretend it never
happened.
Then go through all the public shaming
and then you're dealing with an insanely
rich,
insanely powerful man who was loved by
so many.
And then if there was no previous
allegations,
who the fuck is going to believe you?
Yeah.
Like to a woman in 1996 let's say back
when he was,
you know,
not doing the show anymore,
but he's in his heyday.
Right.
It's loved by everybody and he's
drugging checks and I'm like,
she's probably like to,
how does this,
this can't be.
Yeah,
I'll just fuck it.
I'll just eat it.
I'll just deal with it.
Is deal with it.
But then they,
it fucks with them,
I'm sure for a long time.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
Could you imagine?
Well,
that was the weirdest thing is that some
of them claimed they were,
that he was like in a mentorship role
with them.
I got help you with your career.
I'll do this and have a coffee.
That was his moves is power move.
Yeah.
That's sounds to me more.
Is there more?
You want more
good.
What is this?
Butter coffee.
And that's a caveman coffee with a
little grass fed butter and some mct
oil.
It's good for the soul.
That's lovely.
Just feel right.
Lovely.
I felt good.
So,
um,
you're a trump supporter,
right?
Big Time Man.
Southern
California chapter head.
These Bernie Sanders people been fucking
tweet,
not me.
There's so mad because I said that
Bernie Sanders supported,
uh,
90% taxing of the rich apparently is not
exactly true.
Uh,
this is what assault course,
correct it for the Bernie Sanders people
cause they get upset.
What he did say was they're talking
about marginal tax rate,
which that means if you make over a
certain amount,
how much should you tax?
And we're gonna cap that are now,
he was saying that for a marginal tax
rate,
uh,
would you,
is 90% too high?
He said No.
And that's for extremely wealthy people.
So like say if you make,
let's say if you make 10 million bucks a
year,
everything over 10 million bucks,
they would tax at 90% and I'm just
coming up with a number for 10 but the,
the regular,
and he thinks it's not too much to tax
90% over amount.
But the problem with this kind of
thinking is,
well people say,
Ooh,
it's going to help other people.
It's going to be a good for other
people.
Not necessarily.
The problem with that kind of thinking
is that money goes to the government and
the government is a bunch of fucking
monkeys.
Yeah.
That's the reality.
It's not,
it's not like an insanely ethical,
really educated,
super smart,
really disciplined,
conservative,
fiscally conservative person who's gonna
take care of this money and allocated
correctly.
No,
you're going to give it to the
government and you get to create bigger
government and got to create
bureaucracy,
red tape,
more people,
more bullshit,
more jobs that are bullshit jobs.
It's not necessarily going to help
people.
And then he,
he,
I think Bernie Sanders says a lot of
good shit.
Like people that think that I'm a,
I'm Bernie Sanders Hater.
He says a lot of good shit.
I like what he says about marijuana,
but he says some fucking silly shit too.
Here's one of the things that he said
that drove me crazy.
You don't necessarily need a choice of
23 underarm spray deodorants or 18
different pairs of sneakers when
children are hungry in this country.
Those two things are totally unrelated.
What's his,
that's totally unrelated.
Like what if you wanted to open up a
fucking deodorant company,
you shouldn't be able to open up a
deodorant company because children are
starving,
so you should work to to feed children
what's instead of renting in which he
said that though.
I mean we was just talking about the
economy.
It's just talking about the world and
the idea of a choking on choice.
You know,
if too much,
too many toys that we have too many
choices that we divert our,
but here's the thing,
when you think about these choices,
you're talking about these choices that
are created by whatever percentage,
whatever number of 300 million people,
that has nothing to do with whether or
not poor people get fed.
It just doesn't.
Right.
And the what in taking money away from
wealthy people,
it doesn't have anything to do with
whether or not poor people get fed.
I think that one of the things that he
said that I agree with wholeheartedly is
they need to stop people,
these corporations from hiding their
money overseas where they don't have to
pay taxes on it.
Yeah,
a hundred percent hundred percent I
think that's fucking criminal.
If you want all the benefits of living
in America,
you want all the benefits that are
provided to you by this free country,
but you want to store your money
overseas,
fuck you,
and you don't want to pay taxes on that.
Fuck you.
But maybe there's some compromise where
that tax rate does get adjusted for that
a little bit so that they have the
incentive.
Right.
Cause the right cat over here.
Yeah.
Because right now the reason they're
saying well I'm going to keep it over
there cause I'm saving so much fucking
money but they make so much money.
Yeah,
I agree.
I'm just saying those are greedy Kershaw
for sure they are.
Because you're talking about people that
are making insane amounts of money that
are doing that.
People that are barely bought theirs.
So I think in that sense,
yeah they,
that's,
I'm a hundred percent with him on that
and corporate tax shelters,
there's a lot of like really sneaky shit
where you find out companies made
billions of dollars and they paid almost
nothing in taxes cause it's shelters.
Shame.
I'm 100% with him on that.
I think he's got a lot of really good
points.
He's got a really,
I mean he's 100% down with pot.
I appreciate that.
His position on cannabis is,
it's totally on unnecessary and criminal
to have it illegal.
I believe 100% on that and I also
support them 100% on the idea of a
living wage.
Like if somebody works 40 hours a week,
they should be able to feed themselves
and have a roof over their head.
Yeah,
I'm 100% down with that.
I think a minimum wage for a kid who's
in high school or something like that,
it's still lives their parents.
That's one thing and I think there are
entry level jobs like that where someone
should make whatever it is,
but it should be enough where you could
live.
You know if you are,
if you're a person who's 18 years or
older and you're working at a job and
you are spending eight hours of every 24
hours a day working for someone,
you should make a living.
You should be able to feed yourself
without worry.
Clothe yourself.
I'm not talking about opulence,
I'm not talking about wealth driving a
Mercedes,
but you should definitely be able to
take care of yourself should.
I think the problem with that when
people cause a lot,
I think a lot of people would agree with
that is it's always,
well how are we going to,
who's going to pay for that?
In other words,
the idea is right and then you go,
where?
Where will the money come from to
support making that a reality?
Well,
I think the money's got to come.
I mean,
it's gotta be profitable business,
right?
Right.
So if you've got a profitable business,
how much of the profit goes to the
employees and how much of the profit
goes to the owner of the business?
Sure.
Like say if you have a diamond business,
right,
and you're selling diamonds and your
employees are making $5 an hour,
that's kind,
Kinda fucked up.
You know,
like you're making millions and you're
paying your employee $5 an hour.
What is it,
seven now,
what's the minimum?
I have no idea.
See,
and that's obviously an extreme example,
but in that extreme example,
yeah,
man,
you need to pay more money to people who
work for you.
If someone do,
if they didn't work for you,
your job wouldn't work.
Like you need someone say if you run a
car manufacturing business,
right?
Yeah.
If you don't have employees that put
together those cars,
you literally don't have cars so you
don't have anything to sell.
So you need to pay those fucking people
because they are the reason why your
car's getting made.
And if they do a good job,
they should be paid.
Well,
I totally agree with you.
I mean,
nothing is,
it's,
it's horrible when somebody applies
themselves to a job and can't sustain
the minimum.
Yeah.
Like having a place to live,
paying for food.
It's terrible.
I totally agree.
I,
the only thing that I'm not smart enough
to definitely figure out is,
well,
what is that number?
And then,
uh,
you know,
do you then dictate to different places
of business?
It's got to be this number or it's gotta
be this percentage,
at least,
you know.
How do you,
how do you make it a reality?
I don't know,
man.
I do know that like Obamacare,
according to everyone that I know that
runs a business is a fucking disaster,
really can.
It's costing people way more money and
costing businesses way more money.
I've yet to hear anybody make a
convincing argument why,
why it works.
But on the other hand,
I'm a fan of the idea of socialized
medicine.
Sure.
I think that medicine should be just
like the police and the fire department.
I think you should they the hoop that
people who do it should be paid really
well.
They should have an incentive to want
those jobs and the people should be able
to get the services for free.
I really think that,
I mean I think,
I don't,
I'm not,
I'm not opposed to private doctors.
Yeah.
Like if,
if you're a,
say,
if you're a bad ass fucking knee
surgeon,
you work on the NBA and you work on all
these different people and you're just
the best of what you do,
you should totally be able to work
privately.
But the government could easily allocate
enough money to provide public health
care.
It's just if it's been done in other
countries,
the fact that it can't be done here.
[inaudible] it's been,
they do at other places.
They don't do it well.
It's sucks in England.
It fucking sucks.
Does it really?
Everybody I talked to you that lives
over there and tell you it's a year.
If you hurt yourself,
you get surgery.
You know,
cause people always cite Canada too.
And I'm sure,
yeah,
Canada is a joke too.
Well I know that,
I know a couple of Canadian people that
when shit got serious,
you know,
and they needed to see a cardiovascular
surgeon and they talk about that weight.
They were like,
fuck it,
let's fly over to the Mayo Clinic.
And exactly.
You know,
and then you shut off the money though.
Yeah.
Then you have to come to America and you
have to pay for a hotel and airfare and
who knows if you have that money.
Yeah,
I think,
I think there's gotta be some sort of a
comfortable middle ground,
but it's got to be,
well it's sort of like public school,
you know,
like you can get educated in this
country if you don't have enough money.
Right.
But is it a good education?
No,
a lot of parts is a lot of parts.
Not a lot of parts of California and
Southern California,
Los Angeles,
one of the richest fucking cities and
all of the United States and the schools
are dog shit.
Dog Shit
terribly.
Shouldn't be an excuse for that.
No,
but you know also you're dealing with
crime.
Yeah.
You're dealing with extreme levels of
poverty.
Engineering that and trying to fix that
is not an easy task.
But I just don't think you do that by
limiting the amount of underarm sprays
or toothpastes are fucking the flavors
of ice cream or whatever the fuck you
want to.
I don't see the,
it doesn't make sense.
No,
I just don't know.
I don't know if he's been a businessman
ever.
You know,
I think,
I don't think so.
That's what I like about trump.
I don't like a lot of things about
trump.
I don't like how he talks about
Mexicans.
That shit drives me crazy.
I don't like,
I mean the idea of people sneaking over
here over the border like,
dude,
how do you not have compassion?
And these fucking people are born a
third world country that's attached to
America.
You know?
He knows what he's saying,
what he's doing that he's fucking
around.
Well,
I think he's playing to what he knows.
We'll get people go,
you're goddamn right.
You know that place.
Yeah.
He knows that.
That's that saying those controversial
things that are going to get in the
paper.
Also going to get people going.
Well,
at least someone saying,
you know,
I think he knows that.
I don't think it's an accident.
Yeah.
I think you probably write in a lot of
ways,
but I think he gets a big response from
that and then he feeds off that
response.
Loves it.
But he's a successful businessman.
You know what's something,
someone told me though?
It's really kind of fucked up.
If he took that money that his father
gave him,
his father gave him 2 million bucks to
start his business.
If he took that money and put it in a
mutual account,
uh,
it would be worth way more than he
currently is worth that.
I do not believe I would really check
your friend pretty fucking hard.
I was up.
I a friend,
like someone told me on the hill,
if he makes that money in a fund,
that would have been probably around 35
years ago,
$2 million.
His net worth conservatively is around
four and a half billion.
I mean,
do you really think that,
uh,
a mutual fund would have?
Well,
let's,
let's look at it.
Jamie.
Why don't you a google that if Donald
Trump took the money that his father
gave him and invested it and blank,
there's whatever it is.
Yeah.
I mean,
whatever that,
um,
whatever that equation is.
Let's see.
If he would have bought apple stock,
let me know.
Yeah,
it would have been crazy.
I don't think it'd be four and a half.
What about Google?
Oh,
Shit.
Oh Shit.
That was some big money.
I thought that,
oh shit,
but you know it's funny is that he goes,
I'm worth 10 billion and Forbes did this
breakdown of all his assets,
and they go,
no,
you're not.
He goes,
yeah,
I am.
And I get that.
That's kind of how he argues things is
go,
yeah,
I am though.
You know,
he doesn't have the substance right
facts behind it.
He just says,
yeah,
and they go,
why are you saying that?
He goes,
because it sounds better.
It sounds better to be worth 10 than
four and a half.
Did He admit that?
He said that?
He said it's because it sounds better,
and they said too.
In other words,
if he were to make him worth 10 he would
have to,
he was,
he'd be inflating the value of a lot of
his holdings.
In other words,
it's like saying,
well,
I have this house and it's worth $65
million but nobody wants to buy it.
They're like,
well,
no,
houses in that neighborhood sell for
that.
They sell for 3 million and he goes,
not mine,
my 65.
And that's how he determines that he's
worth 10.
I'm going to start doing that.
That's great.
Just tell people no,
you're wrong.
Yeah.
But I don't think he can hang at all
with the elite politicians when it comes
to substance and knowing actual policy,
knowing details.
That's a good point.
But here's the question.
Is anybody who's running for president
and elite politician?
Well,
I mean you'd have to say that Hillary's
at least way more savvy and knows a lot
more about how,
uh,
certainly you know how the world works.
International Affairs.
I mean she was secretary of state.
She knows the ins and outs of a lot of
what you would assume.
She knows that,
but wouldn't she know not to use a
private email account while she's
secretary of state?
It's crazy.
She go to jail for that.
It's insane.
That's something that if somebody wanted
to push,
that's a crime.
I don't,
you're not allowed to do this.
Still don't understand why even though
it's still discuss how you kind of get
away with that.
Cause it just feels like I don't get it.
But I mean she's certainly more savvy
politician.
I think that trump,
I don't know what his savvy though.
Well cause he's saying shit that's led
him to a 39% lead over any other
candidate in the Republican Party.
Remember when Ben Carson?
Yeah.
It was like on the the cost line.
He's,
he was ahead of them at one point in
time.
It,
he was,
yeah,
that all dry it up.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
I think people are really into the idea
of the fantasy of a trump,
you know?
But I still think if you get to a
debate,
it's not that he wouldn't win.
Maybe he'd win,
but it would be based on,
well,
you know,
you're a fucking loser.
Like it's like that guy,
he says shit like that.
But it,
it's weird.
No one ever does that.
But it seems to work.
It's that.
Yeah.
And then I,
then I guess you could argue,
see he is savvy.
Yeah.
But I mean,
you know,
I guess he's not savvy in the
traditional sense.
I don't think he knows the INS and outs
of the way a lot of things work.
I think his whole thing is,
look,
I'm super successful and I'll get it
done.
Yeah.
But the wildlife,
lot of the ways that things work or kind
of bullshit,
you know,
crony politics and influenced by
gigantic corporations,
he doesn't have that same sort of
influence cause he's independently
wealthy.
Right.
There's a lot of weirdness to that.
There is like special interest groups
don't really have the same sort of pull
on him that they have on other people
know they can't own them.
They would never let him say the shit
that he's saying
no.
And lots of put a wall between us and
Mexico and call it the trump wall.
I just,
his fucking name,
here's what doesn't use me anytime.
If so,
if,
if this is
CNN and [inaudible] your host of CNN
show and I'm somebody saying like,
well,
you know,
trump is a,
he's completely unqualified in this
claim.
He made his idiotic.
He then tweets saw Tom Segura on CNN.
Guys always been a fucking loser for
whoever,
whoever says anything bad.
He'll be like,
yeah,
saw his show last week,
not one laugh,
exclamation point.
Like shit like that.
He does that for everyone.
That's what Ronda Rousey,
when Rhonda got knocked out,
he did.
He said,
I'm glad she lost.
She was,
she's not a good person.
Whoa.
And you know why I did that?
Because she uh,
he had claimed that she was a trump
supporter and then she said,
no,
I support Bernie Sanders.
And he was like,
Oh really?
Oh yeah.
So when she lost it was like before that
he was saying that she was interested a
supporter.
He was like all for it.
Yeah.
Rhonda Rousey supports me and she was
like,
the fuck I do.
And he's like,
she's not a good person.
Glad you go off.
I'll lose her.
Pretty interesting way of just a loser,
the loser,
a loser,
but always been a loser.
Bunch of losers.
Remember when she was,
he was going back and forth and look at
that.
Glad to see that Ronda Rousey lost her
championship fight last night was
soundly beaten dash.
Not a nice person.
The fuck are you talking about?
Well,
what about you?
You're way more of a dick.
She's at least not a nice person to sell
massive amounts of fucking paper view
sales.
Yeah.
And,
and you know,
be the protagonist.
He tweets about everybody.
Uh,
the,
if they write an article in the
Washington Post,
the Washington Post,
which has been on the decline for years,
had an article written by this loser.
He writes.
I know.
It's pretty funny.
It's sad.
Sad.
Not a nice person.
Yeah,
you're fired.
Like that's his whole thing.
You know,
I was a,
they gave me an offer to,
to be on that show.
I was going to do it.
I was thinking about,
really talked to him,
the family,
like you guys want to live in New York
for a few months,
but um,
you know,
they fire you in the beginning.
They do all that.
You're fired stuff in the beginning.
Oh really?
So you don't have a chance to go faulk
you.
Oh really?
Yeah,
like before,
before anyone knows anybody's fired,
he fires everybody.
Tom,
you're fired.
And then you get up and leave.
Jamie,
you're fired and you get up and walk
away.
Joe,
you're fired.
You get up and walk away and then they
do the show.
Okay.
Yeah.
So you don't,
you don't get a chance to say,
let me tell you what I think about you
and your fucking plastic hair.
You cunt.
You fucking sloppy dummy.
Who got lucky.
That was probably done once and he was
like,
that's not going to happen again.
Well probably right.
I think he probably planned for in
advance.
He's probably pretty good chess player.
Yeah.
I got to look like I'm always the king.
But they canceled that show after we
talk shit about Mexicans.
Yeah.
And macy's and
did their partnership.
They had a whole line of,
you know,
trump ties and shirts,
trump ties.
And they were like,
we're done.
We're done with you.
And then Miss Universe threatened to,
or NBC threatened to not air his thing,
posted the contract and he was like,
I'll steal your balls off.
You know,
NBC had a contract with him to Air Miss
Universe.
He,
he doesn't Miss Universe.
It's his,
well he sold it,
but he owned,
he owned Miss Universe and maybe Miss
America to be on those various pageants.
Yeah.
It's just to be around checks.
He like,
he literally thought those to be around
that shit.
For sure.
That's a good move on his part.
It's a gangster move.
I'm a billionaire.
I bought a pageant.
Hmm.
Then he just,
I like the Czech Republic this year.
Yeah.
What is this?
I find it kind of like some more
information about what he inherited.
Okay.
Uh,
he was also,
when his father died in 1974,
him and his siblings took over a $200
million real estate business,
which he may have gotten around $40
million of the bottom of this says if he
invested that and since 1974 and the s
and p 500,
he could be worth around 3 billion
today.
Okay.
So it kind of makes sense.
Right.
But that's also 40 million,
not to just the one or whatever he was
given.
And what does it say?
So it was current claim network of 8.7
billion would equate to around 120
million in 1974 which is right in the
middle estimates of what he inherited.
So that means if he invested that,
that doesn't make any sense.
That's confused.
It says the s and P is up 74 or 74 fold
since 1974 I see you didn't do anything
and just left it there.
It'd be about 120 million.
But if he did other chances and other
got good business,
things went well for him.
It could be worth up to three.
Okay,
so what they're saying is here,
here's a clear example,
says if he had invested the 40 million
in an s and p 500 index fund,
he'd be worth about 3 billion today,
which is in line with the third party
estimates of 3 billion and 4 billion,
which is his net worth.
So they estimate between three and 4
billion.
Yeah.
Which is probably right.
Still baller.
Well are still baller,
doesn't have to listen.
You can do whatever he wants.
How fucking good.
I liked it.
He's making a mockery of the whole
thing.
I like a lot of things about him.
I in apparently Jeff Ross who,
uh,
did the trump rose says he's a good guy.
So you talked to him.
He's a good guy.
Like he knows what he's doing.
You know a lot of this like fucking
fanfare and this craziness and all this
shit that he's doing.
He's mocking this stupid fucking system.
He's a smart guy.
He knows what he's doing.
I mean,
look,
he's talked shit about Mexicans and he's
still the fucking front runner in a
giant way.
He's like,
well,
someone's raping someone's birding and
we're going to let a bunch of rapists
and murderers over there.
I'm sure you said Pete,
everyone over there is a rapist and
rent.
Well,
someone's raping.
Yeah.
Who's doing all the,
but he's just like,
he says crazy shit like that and like
hits it flies in the face of,
look what happened to that poor fuck the
Mormon.
What the fuck's his name?
Uh,
that ran for president last time.
I know you're the fuck's his name.
Romney.
That poor fuck.
All he said was,
we don't have to pay attention to the
47% that aren't going to vote for us.
Yeah.
The the lower 47% that make little
money,
they're not going to vote for us in the
first place,
so let's not pay attention.
Then that tanked his business.
That tanked.
It tanked it.
They're like,
it's over.
It's over,
bitch.
I know it's over.
How about Howard Dean?
All we did was cheer
and that was it.
That was it.
You fragile bitch.
You can't even cheer.
You can't cheer.
He can't scream and trump can say
mexicans are rapists and everybody's
like,
Ooh,
El Chapo wants to Muslims at the border.
Yeah,
we should stop letting him in so crazy.
Like this is a country founded by
letting people in.
Did you?
Only way this country got filled is
letting people in,
not old people.
These people are running.
They're leaving their country because
radical Muslim terrorists if taken over
it.
Yeah.
What was that?
His new ad.
The first ad came out.
This,
what is it?
What is it?
His first ad.
Oh my God,
you're kidding.
But this was the beginning of Craig it
and I approve this message.
The politicians can pretend it's
something else,
but Donald Trump calls it radical
Islamic terrorism.
That's why he's calling for a temporary
shutdown of Muslims entering the United
States until we can figure out what's
going on,
you'll quickly cut the head off my sis
and take their oil and he'll stop
illegal immigration by building a wall
on our southern border that Mexico will
pay for it.
Wow.
Okay.
He got flack for that shot of the people
running.
That's not where they were from there.
That was a shot of Morocco.
Yeah.
It's pretty fun.
It's not America.
It's not running across about,
he'll so just get me some brown people
running.
Any Brown people running in black and
white footage.
We'll take it.
Yeah.
He's entertaining.
I will give him that as a show.
This is a fun show to watch.
It's the best show ever.
I hope him and Hillary debate.
I hope he gets to debate on the long
side cause I think he'll crush her.
Do you think your husband will be back
in the White House getting blow jobs
like he was?
Oh yeah.
He's going to throw some grenades.
Oh,
sure.
He doesn't give a fuck detonate some.
Yeah,
it will be awesome.
It will be anything.
Ben Carson should be involved too,
just to tell us that the earth is 10,000
years old and Jesus wrote a Unicorn.
Yeah.
Through the fucking,
that garden of Eden.
Doctor fucking awesome.
Doctor Brain's amazing.
Neurosurgeon,
one of the greatest neurosurgeons this
country has ever produced that really,
that,
that accomplished.
Oh,
100% yeah,
and he doesn't believe in evolution.
Well,
he believes,
he'll say,
well,
I believe in certain types of
evolutions.
He's got a,
I don't think he's a 10,000 year guy.
I don't think he's one of the young
Earth Christians,
but Sarah Pailin was,
Sarah Pailin,
talked to allegedly,
obviously this is all anecdotal,
but she allegedly talk to a librarian in
Alaska and told the library and that she
saw photos on the Internet of a dinosaur
footprint with a human footprint inside
of it.
What?
Which means dinosaurs and people were in
the same area.
Walking.
Is that on?
Is that recorded?
That said,
oh,
it'd be amazing if it was.
Yeah.
A lot of young Earth Christians,
man.
How did the how,
I don't know the argument of that they
make for,
you know,
carbon footprinting things cause that's
how shit,
that's just a bullshit.
Losers.
Not a nice person.
Yeah.
Oh,
that guy that said,
that's fucking dog.
I know you're talking about,
he's always been a loser.
I'm waiting for the day when no one runs
for president.
I'm waiting for the day where the
fucking roster everybody gives up.
It's like as soon as we can read minds
and figure out exactly what people,
what their intention is and what their
past is,
and you have to sign up for the mind
reading machine in order for to be
president.
That's going to be the end.
There was,
eh,
it's rap.
I do think I look at it so much
differently now at this age.
When I see people,
I'm like,
you're just,
they're all just egomaniacs.
Oh yeah.
Their egos are climbing out of their
skin to,
to want to be,
to go through that to be the president.
Well,
Obama's publicly stated that it's not
what he thought it was.
And then all these people that are
lining up to do it like Filson the fame
wears off as what he said and that
people criticized him by taking that
quote out of context and showing a bunch
of pictures of him with famous people
smiling and laughing,
handing out with Jay z and rich people
and ha ha ha.
Ah,
and then there was this whole story
about his,
uh,
vacations.
How much is vacations costs while he was
in the White House?
The president's vacations cost a ton.
Yeah,
of course they will.
They have to fly in air force one and
they got secret service vehicles.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
Well they have bulletproof cars.
I have to,
what was his Hawaiian vacations?
Apparently during his time in the White
House,
it's been $70 million.
Taxpayers had to pay a lot of money.
It's a little pricey.
He's,
it's great.
It is a little pricey,
but you know,
it's kind of trumped up man.
We had a great time on that trip number.
Often he was golfing 70 million.
Not a trip we took.
Yeah,
I mean he was golfing like when the San
Bernandino murders were taking place,
he went golfing out.
There was a little skinny legs picking
up golf balls.
Yeah,
it doesn't do any squats do.
There's a shooting going on man.
I'm trying to play this back.
Nine if you like,
give me a second.
Why do they all play golf?
Can you be president?
There's two things you can't be if you
want to be president.
You can't be someone who doesn't believe
in God when you can't be someone who
doesn't play golf.
Um,
I think we're about to see maybe a
change of that.
What Hillary,
I don't think the pictures,
she's going to be golf.
And if she wins Bernie,
do you think if he won he would play?
First of all,
I'll make golf illegal and I'll turn off
the place of intense places where the
homeless people,
yeah,
would be like these courses,
a waste of space.
They are.
Yeah.
The cough is,
I don't have a good Bernie impression.
I need to get a good brand seen.
I think it James [inaudible] who was at
the,
he's a comic and an actor.
He doesn't find it.
How do you spell his last name?
I think it's a d.
O.
M I.
A N.
[inaudible]
james a domain.
I think that's it.
Oh,
you know what else does a good one?
Really funny.
Steven crowder,
he calls Bernie clause.
Steven crowder fucking mocks Bernie
pretty heavy.
Really?
Yeah.
He's pretty funny.
And this is a Bernie clause impression
crap.
You know,
crowder is,
and he's kind of like an internet
comedian,
but politically conservative.
He does.
Uh,
he did a really funny thing.
You know,
social justice warriors are always
saying that you should ask people what
their correct gender pronouns are
because some people like to useZ and h I
r and all these different that
nonconventional gender pronouns because
they,
they're either gender queer and uh,
they don't,
they don't want to be labeled in a
specific male or female gender.
You're set up for this as exhausting to
you.
Now
I want to punch whoever fucking told you
this.
It's the worst thing I've ever heard.
I'm having an aneurysm right now
thinking about where this is going to
go.
See your pay attention to throat,
zillow
and I'm paying attention to ridiculous
social requirements that people in
college today or we're asking people to
do and they want people to ask other
people's social,
uh,
you know,
like they have like this real rigid idea
of how you supposed to behave socially
and you're supposed to ask their
preferred gender pronouns.
Like,
I can't just assume that you are a man.
I have to ask you.
I'm not kidding.
You know,
there's a guy,
we had this guy on who was a guest who
said that one of his colleagues was,
I think it was fired because he refused
to this.
He had a student in his class that would
change his gender pronoun from him to
her and her to him.
And it would go back forth,
back and forth depending on what days of
the week.
Like some days he wanted to be a girl
and some days he wanted to be a boy.
And this,
this professor was not willing to do
that.
And so he was fired.
Good for the professor.
That's one where I a hundred percent
support.
If you're going back and forth on today,
she is here and tomorrow he might be
back tomorrow.
I'mZ ,
I'm not her z.
And then the next day I'm hr her.
All right.
I give the fuck up.
Well,
you know,
Harvard released a list of possible
gender pronouns and so they sent it home
with people to like,
I want you to be aware of these
potential gender pronouns and gender
neutral pronouns that you should be
aware of that people want them to use.
Fuck me.
I would just
walk around.
I would go,
he,
and then if someone's like,
no,
I'd be like,
whatever.
Sorry.
You're right.
Hey Jesus.
You can't have a fucking Thompson Jura
style beard and b,
she,
her maybe he z your Z,
Z,
z.
Z.
Sigora mister,
can I say Mr?
No,
no.
Well,
when he was in class,
oh,
excuse me.
When Zee Zee was in class when her was
in class.
Chai are there really are using uh oh
yeah.
Z.
H.
Here it is.
Gender Binary.
These are gender binary.
He,
she hurt him but gender neutral.
Are they them?
Theirs like some people on their twitter
page to have a preferred gender.
Pronouns use pronouns.
Zi Hr,
ours,
Here.
Here's here.
How about here?
Pronunciation.
H I r is here.
It's not even her.
Z.
Z are zeroes.
Zeroes,
sometimes z.
If you get crazy,
they spell it with an x.
Z.
It's like another class.
I would have failed because I would
really,
I a run right through the fucking door.
You never even bothered to open it me
out.
Oh,
I would've been like the Kool aid guy.
I would have left my outline like in the
car.
Yes.
Gone.
I'm gone.
I'm not doing it,
man.
I'm really not though.
What the fuck man,
what is going on?
I'll tell you what's going on.
Everybody got a trophy participation
trophies.
Yeah,
I'm against that for sure.
That's what did it.
Everybody got attention for who they
are.
I'm amazing on my own,
right.
No,
I'm here.
I'm Zaire.
How remember,
you know,
losing games and,
and,
and it sucked.
That was part of the thing is that you
remember,
it sucks.
Yeah.
Well that's why winning is awesome.
Winning is awesome.
Not a loser.
Yeah.
When no one's a loser,
winning is an awesome anymore.
Right.
Cause everybody gets participation
trophies.
No.
Yeah.
Well My,
my daughter when she was three,
she was playing soccer and no one won.
I was like,
what do you mean no one won?
This team scored five,
that team scored zero.
That team fucking one.
Nope.
We don't celebrate that.
I have,
I'm going to look into,
uh,
a League for my kid that definitely has
winners and losers.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
Well,
when my daughter played softball too,
and she was six,
this was not even the young,
the three year old that when,
uh,
my seven year old was six.
She was playing softball and they didn't
count the score.
I don't get it.
Then they would run and everybody high
five,
everybody,
nobody count score.
They wouldn't count.
It's just about playing the bullshit.
Bullshit.
What?
What's the point in hitting the ball
then?
Yeah.
How about we just throw the ball around?
How about you just hit balls randomly?
Someone's pitching,
you're trying to hit it.
If you don't hit it,
you're a loser.
Okay.
Yeah,
you suck at this.
You know what?
I sucked at tee ball or the ball sits on
the t and it doesn't move.
I had trouble with that.
I couldn't hold.
That's the other thing they do with
kids.
If they can't hit the pitch,
they gave him a couple of pitches and
they can't hit it.
Then they put it on a little stick and
they let the,
they set it up for them and they hit it
and they get them on base for sure.
Yeah,
and a lot of them,
they don't mean hit the fucking stealing
with the ball.
They hit the stick itself and the ball
falls down and they just start running
like they just won the world series.
Yeah.
I got an a tee ball pretty quick,
you know,
I was like,
I suck at this shit.
[inaudible]
I was bad at every sport until I did
martial arts.
I was pretty okay at baseball,
but uh,
I wasn't a good baseball player because
I wouldn't listen to the coach ever.
They would say go on there and try to
hit a single.
Okay.
Whatever.
And I get up to home run every time.
Yeah.
Every time.
Swing for the bleachers.
You know why?
Cause I hit a couple of them and it was
awesome.
The best,
when you feel that,
take that crack of the bat and that ball
starts flying through the air,
you like,
Yay.
Sweet spot feeling man.
There's that feeling that you only get
when you hit a home run course.
You don't get that feeling when you get
on base.
No.
That's like,
oh,
okay.
I'm not a loser.
When you get on base,
you're like,
I'm not a loser one.
Yeah.
You watched that thing fucking sale
under the bleachers.
You're a winner.
Winner.
Now you're a winner.
Yo One.
I agree in a home run,
he'd come back,
everybody's high fiving you.
And the coach is like,
I told you,
get on base.
You could fuck all the way off,
dummy.
I just hit a home run.
Yeah,
that's why in in football,
they always tried to teach you that when
you tackle to wrap up,
you know,
they're like lower your body,
head to the side,
shoulder into the chest,
and then you wrap up.
But you know what you try to do?
You Try to light people up,
throw fucking,
and you miss,
you know the guy who bounces off of it.
But every once in a while you lay
somebody the fuck out and you're like,
what's up now?
So that's,
that's why you do that.
You know,
he goes,
what?
You do that?
What the fuck is wrong with these
coaches?
Coach raising a bunch of pussies,
they want to be called Z or her or Zarr
Shit is zero.
Zero.
Um,
well,
let's see the Bernie impression.
We have it.
Yeah.
Do we fire it up?
What's his name again?
James a doe Meehan.
Where's he at?
He's,
he's here.
He's an La guy.
Oh,
okay.
Paul,
let's go full screen on this bitch.
Give James a domains.
So props.
Yeah,
he's,
he's funny,
Dude.
Partisan that Donald Trump versus Bernie
Sanders
walling
for president,
but I thought of the Moody of Military
Coup de Paul for like we all know power
all pro football.
That's really good.
It's really good.
This is a great country.
This is a fun place.
It's pretty good too.
Yeah,
and I promise I'm killing everyone in
the bowls.
I can guarantee this.
I'm killing everyone in the post and if
I'm elected president,
I will kill everyone.
Listen fast.
Okay.
The minute I'm become president at the
anchor baby program where we start
bronzing Mexican immigrants and putting
them on naval ships put to use.
Finally,
I'm just saying bronze and make it a
real thing.
No,
it's no longer in events and metaphor.
You'll look like a warning shot
here
on the left to the right.
It's two weeks were how out in a car.
Fairly mature.
Hold on.
Happened while I was simultaneously
buying stock
pile.
Where are your final courteous way
completely blow up.
I have more hair,
but I didn't want to ask.
That's great.
And so I don't know the trump guys name,
but he's great.
Yeah.
What is his name was the trump press.
If you highlight the video yet.
Anthony,
what is it,
James Alimony in a domain.
A domain to me at a manwich boy.
Yeah.
Both immigrants.
Obviously names.
Yeah.
Probably Muslim terrorists snuck problem
probably.
That's funny.
He doesn't really get trump to,
yeah,
that's good.
That trump is good.
It's really good.
Put that fucking Bernie Sanders is on
point.
It really is a long haul.
And talking about the percentages of the
percentage,
he got the uh,
the substance of it down to,
well,
everybody's looking for somebody that
comes along.
It stands out as being the counter to
what we're experiencing,
you know?
Yeah.
No one feels like any of these people
represent them,
except maybe Ted Cruz fans is a few
fucking a few Weirdos.
I liked the guys that still stay in it,
you know,
when they know there's not even a shot
of that level of denial.
There's,
you're just in denial.
It was a pride thing.
Yeah.
But there's a certain point where you
know there's not,
it's not going to turn around and they
still like,
I'm,
I don't know,
I'm still got a shot.
You know,
you don't have a shot.
I mean,
is Jeff still in it?
She's still in it.
I think jeb is land back.
This is my thought.
My thought is jeb is rope a dope and
he's letting all these people beat each
other
up and he's laying way back and I think
he's going to be the eventual Republican
nominee.
That's exactly.
Yeah.
It doesn't meet.
His numbers are terrible,
aren't they?
I mean,
Yup.
And he's not trying,
I'm not trying to do anything about it.
It's got a long way to go.
Yeah.
November.
Right.
Which is almost a year from now.
Think about what can happen publicly in
a year,
in a year.
People become superstars from no name to
superstars in this world.
The world we're experiencing today.
Yeah,
that's true.
This is a different world.
Like you gotta be careful.
And if you're a media savvy guy,
and I got to assume that anybody who
grows up where his fucking dad was
president and his brother was president.
Boy,
if anybody understands that business,
it's him and Hillary.
Yeah.
He looks so tired.
She looks like she's exhausted.
She looks exhausted.
She looks super unhealthy.
Here's a thought.
Ready?
Hillary Clinton
and Christie Brinkley or essentially the
same age,
are they,
aren't they?
I Dunno.
I bet they are.
I bet they're fucking clothes.
Who would you rather hookup with a
hillary?
Just for the story.
Yeah.
That's good.
Sorry,
Christie Brinkley.
It's like,
so you're gonna Marie,
your Bro.
Yeah.
Well the hillary like,
Hey,
what were you thinking dude?
Christie Brinkley
fuck had Viagara in me.
Yeah,
I did 200 milligrams of Viagara.
I did 10 lines of coke.
I drank a bottle of Tequila.
I was on ecstasy and mushrooms.
She's,
she's had a real dog too,
so she's had some savage sex,
I think.
You know,
I think so.
Sure.
She probably hasn't been fucked in
forever.
That's probably been a lesbian for the
left 30 or 40 years.
At least.
Just hangs in there with them.
They made a deal.
I think they made a deal.
She just take a picture to get a might
know.
What the fuck do I know?
Talking Shit.
But I got to assume at,
first of all,
if you got a guy like bill,
you get to know him.
You know that dude's a freak.
He's a whip.
His Dick out type freak.
Oh yeah.
He's one of those guys like,
Hey,
how are you?
Whoa,
whoa.
That's my Dick.
Belongs in your mouth.
Look at that,
Christie Brinkley.
Bam,
Bam.
Now look at how,
but that's a a really good picture.
That's a really good picture of Hillary
too,
by the way.
There's some horrific pictures of
Hillary.
Yeah,
you can find some monstrous ones.
That's probably from about 30 40 years
ago to how long ago was that picture?
It's November 21st two months old lies.
That's photoshop.
The same people that,
uh,
the girls are on Instagram,
they use that.
She's listed as 68 and Christie
Brinkley's 61 so seven years,
seven years,
whatever.
There's no way the Christie brick is
going to look that bad in seven years,
but go for a better picture because it
can happen for her.
Look at that.
Look at her face right there.
Get the fuck Outta here,
dude.
She's hot,
but she's also genetically gifted.
You know that's a,
that's a,
that's her gift to look like that Eo.
Meaning there's a lot involved.
It's not just genetics involved.
She certainly was genetically gifted at
the jump to have that bone structure.
Yeah,
but there's a lot involved there.
First of all,
there's massive exercise diet.
Yeah,
for sure.
Gotta be some Botox and some cautious
use of fillers.
Kegels.
Yeah.
Look at that one right there.
Like,
come on man.
That's a hot 35 year old,
right?
That,
how is that possible?
How is that?
That doesn't make any sense.
Why aren't her teeth rotting out of her
fucking head or those,
they can't be real teeth.
Those teeth are made out of ivory.
From murdered elephants.
Yeah.
Had real teeth.
And you know what?
Fucking up my grandmother died when she
was like 64 and her teeth looked like
shit.
Why is she so hot?
I appreciate the effort too.
By the way.
Her forehead would not move if you had a
hundred Mexicans and six trucks trying
to move it.
Yeah.
It's all the moving trucks in the world.
They're not going to make that fucking
forehead move.
That thing is frozen in time.
Like a,
like a bully.
Mammoth trapped underneath a glacier.
Nothing's moving.
Look at it fucking for you.
I did.
She didn't moving.
She barely has some lines in the corner
of her eyes.
That's it.
She's hot as fuck though.
Yeah,
whatever she's doing,
everyone should do it.
We should all do it and by the way,
this is what we're seeing from this rare
of rare,
about 1% of the one,
but then of the one I sent this is,
she is the rarest of the rare when it
comes to like women in their sixties
that are still hot as fuck.
She's 100% hot as fuck.
Right?
That is what women are going to look
like in the future.
There's this doctor,
doctor,
I think he's an impure welling.
They get same guy who created regena
keen that blends pending procedure.
They are literally months away from
launching some new treatment where
reignites your body's ability to produce
Collagen.
And so college in his weight makes your
face turn all hillary like hang and
droop and then it loses all its
elasticity.
They gonna bring that shit right back to
life and your face pops out no more.
When women get those old,
old lady elbows were,
the skin's just hanging.
Nobody wants to see that.
So what will they do?
They'll just,
I don't know.
I don't understand the procedure,
but it'll tighten up on you.
You are going to,
your body's Collagen production is going
to read kickstart.
It's going to just jam back into your
skin and your cells are going to
flourish and they're just going to
fucking look elastic and yeah,
you gotta Oh,
wonderful.
Again,
I like it.
I like us all walking around.
I'll tight faced.
Yeah.
Hot.
Crazy.
Yeah.
You Imagine?
Oh,
ladies are going to snap back to life.
Start strength training again.
Build their butt up.
Woo.
And they'll looking for,
still have old lady feeding.
Uh,
yeah.
Keep socks on heath,
a socks,
big thick socks.
I don't even see the twisted shape
underneath.
He'll crust at,
won't go away.
Ooh,
he'll crust.
Don't they have treatments for that
though?
There's sand it down,
right?
Yeah,
there's commercials for it and Mama
Stone's always trying to things that'll
just shave it off.
But I dunno.
Have you ever seen that show dual
survivor?
Yes.
Wait,
is that the one where it's a couple of
ex military guys and they,
they're wandering around.
Yeah.
And only survive,
drop them off in a lake or something.
It's like sort of a fake version of
survivor man with two dudes.
Yes.
But one of the guys who's a survival
expert,
and I use air quotes for that,
I'm sure he's an expert,
but he's,
he's,
I think his name is cody and he's
completely crazy.
He doesn't wear shoes ever,
ever.
So he goes through the jungle,
one or two,
the jungle barefoot and his feet are a
fucking atrocity to be,
there have to be a crime against nature.
His feet,
he's doesn't wear shoes ever,
ever.
So he's just developed these insanely
thick calluses on his feet,
like his photos of his feet online.
What does that,
well,
that's a good photo.
There's feet look great there,
but you've got to see like what his feet
look like when they get close up on like
the bottoms of them.
I've seen some horrific photos of what
his feet looked like,
but he just walks everywhere through the
jungle.
Like there's this huge,
oh my fucking God.
Look how thick it is.
Cracked and everything.
Jesus Christ,
what's called dual survivor.
Yeah.
There's the bottoms of his feet.
Look at that a lot to
make my eyes water and he got elephant
skin fee.
God.
Yeah,
well that's what people did for sure.
It is weird that we have clothes and
shoes.
Yes.
I mean for years,
I mean obviously many,
many years,
everybody walked and ran everywhere
barefoot,
so yeah.
Well that's why it's strange to see
someone naked.
What are you doing?
How many clothes on?
Ooh,
who's the first person to wear clothes?
Who's the first person to come out of
the cave and you're like,
what the fuck are you doing this kind
get,
I got underwear on and it's a guide.
A Little Dick.
I had to be,
he saw a couple of other things was
like,
what the fuck is that little Dick
started surviving people like that's a
like a trait,
right?
Right.
Somebody with a little deck.
How to fuck somebody like,
but that had to be like,
I mean is it a trait because it's,
everybody's a big Dick has a big dick
son.
I don't know.
You imagine if you have a giant Dick and
your kid has a little tiny micro deck.
Man.
I know.
Fuck you're not my son.
Yeah,
you probably start thinking fucking
whore.
She's banging some little Dick Guy.
She got tired of my big Dick.
I sons,
three weeks old.
Giant hug.
We have no idea about the same size dick
though.
His body proportion wise about lines up.
You imagine if your son was born with
just said giant hard.
Yeah,
he comes out and he's,
why is he up to and bill?
Oh God,
that's hard.
To his
time.
He's a baby.
It's hard every day the balls look big.
How big their body such so small,
the babies and then you just see like a
ball bag that stands out for half side
the size of the baby.
Do you know that the size of the
testicles is directly proportionate to
the amount of promiscuous women who are
in the area?
Well,
there's some fucking sluts where I live
cause he's,
he's got a big balls on them.
Well they actually say that the human
body adapts to the amount of promiscuous
women that are in the area and your
balls so crazy.
It's how it is with primates.
The more promiscuous the women are in
the area of the larger the testicles are
of the primate.
That's why chimps have giant balls.
But gorillas have little tiny balls,
little tiny balls and little tiny dicks
for chimps,
for gorillas,
for gorillas.
Because chimp,
chimp,
women are hookers right there.
Just sluts.
But gorilla women,
they mind their PS and qs if fucking
keep it in line,
right?
The gorilla has,
right gorilla has a Harem.
He's got a Harem big fucking pile of
bitches and it just sticks his little
tiny digging them
to champion the chimp.
They just fuck everybody fucks
everybody.
And when you're not looking at me,
funny,
the super slutty but knows they must
have some giant dicks.
Giant balls.
Yup.
They're balls.
Chimp balls are giant and that's the
reason why they're giant.
But they ha they have observed that in
humans,
like,
like the dirt,
there's a direct relation to the size of
the testicles because the more sluts
they're on the area,
the more competition there is to get
your sperm and so you have to produce
more sperm.
So you have to have larger balls.
Yeah.
How about that?
That's something man,
I didn't know that.
Nuts and primates,
there's a direct connection.
They used to think that there was
different kinds of sperm.
There was a book written called sperm
wars,
but it's been largely disproven.
And the idea behind that book was that
there's different kinds of sperm.
This actual sperm that attack other
sperm,
they go in there and the attack others
perm,
that turns out to not be true.
There's no evidence that sperm have any
other duty other than coming,
you know,
hitting eggs and trying to get people
pregnant.
They don't have any other properties.
They don't actually kill.
Sounds like a good premise for a movie
though.
It sounds like an awesome promise.
Killer Jews.
Yeah,
she went blind.
She got the killer as in her eyes.
No sperm.
Yeah.
Like it.
If you like around a lot of promiscuous
women,
like on a porn set,
then that ges that gets in a girl's eyes
could probably blind her cause it's just
looking at kill other sperm
burrow into your eye.
Like little fucking piranhas.
It's chewing away through this or if
outer a on one of those,
those,
those mugs that it starts bubbling cause
there's main ones in there like fucking
feeding frenzy in the Mug.
If you bet a bunch of guys is in
gang fight in the calm,
like I don't want to drink it,
drink it.
It's frothing like boiling water.
Have you ever gone fishing?
Um,
where there's a feeding frenzy?
Uh,
yes I have actually.
I was in Mexico and it was awesome man,
because a,
I took my kids fit,
my kids love fishing.
It's really fun.
Yeah,
they love it because it's,
it's fun for little kids.
Like if you can get them like near where
the fish are and they actually catch
one,
so exciting and then they get to eat it.
They are so happy.
Like we caught this,
I'm eating it and we caught it mommy.
Like they're so excited.
But we um,
we went out in Mexico and there was like
a hundred yards,
like a football field size of all these
uh,
Jack's like Amber Jacks,
I guess there are skipjacks and they
were crushing these bait fish.
So they are like anchovies or something
like that or minnows,
whatever the fuck it is.
And they're smashing these things and
the whole like football field size is
just frothing and all you had to do is
get close to it and cast a lure in
there.
Bam.
And the girls are like,
they're holding onto the rod and I have
to hold on to that with them.
Otherwise,
like the fish will literally pull the
rod in the water.
It was wild,
man.
It's wild.
Yeah.
Fishing is a pretty good time.
I haven't done it in a wild fucking,
I love it.
It's fun.
So Fun,
man.
I just love the idea that you could go
out into that water and catch lunch.
You just go out of here and bring home
dinner.
Yeah.
That's again,
not a store.
And if you ever had fish that's caught
like they prepared it for us.
We caught a couple different kinds of
fish.
We caught a,
um,
when I was in Hawaii,
we call it an,
oh no,
I'm going to call it,
or it's a Wahoo,
but they call them Ono's and I'm an ono
is dalicious.
It's such a delicious fish and the sh,
it's a big fish too.
So we couldn't have even eaten all of
it.
So I gave half of it to the guy who ran
the boat and then we took half of it.
Half of the fish was enough for my whole
family.
Everybody ate it and they ate it.
They prepared a bunch of different ways.
They made Sushimi out of it.
They made like a,
they baked it and they grilled it.
So they gave us like three different
preparations and the Oh,
they even made some Vj.
Yeah,
they made CV chairs.
What city were you in doing?
This was in,
uh,
that was in Maui.
Wow.
Yeah,
it was a really awesome man.
That's,
no actually that was on the big island,
but um,
I love Hawaiian man.
I wish it wasn't so far.
I know,
but that's why it's awesome.
It's cause it's so far.
Yeah.
If it was right there it'd be like
Mexico.
You just go right there.
But Mexico is pretty bad ass too,
man.
You go there recently,
Mexico.
Yeah,
I was there last year.
Uh,
area.
Um,
Punto Tomita okay.
It's called,
is that important by artos or what it
is?
I Dunno.
I've been,
I went to the loom.
Taloon was nice.
That was cool.
Um,
the next time I go,
I want to go where the Aztec Pyramids
are.
Cause when I was in Mexico City,
I've been in Mexico City twice last year
for the UFC and a,
but I want to go,
man,
I just fucking chill in my hotel and
work out.
It's pretty crazy city,
right?
It's nuts.
Yeah.
It's chaos.
First of all,
the pollution is worse than anything
you've ever seen in your life.
Really?
Oh my God.
I took photos and put it on my instagram
and people thought it was bullshit.
Really?
It's insane.
Like the photos on instagram that I put
up,
it looks like you're in a fire like it
looks like,
is that bad?
Oh,
it's crazy.
It's way worse than La.
It's like Yelei in 20 years if if Donald
Trump becomes president.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's the biggest city in the world,
is it?
Yeah,
I believe so.
More than it.
Chinese cities like Beijing,
there's harm people,
so,
right,
right.
I tell him,
no,
I,
I'm pretty sure it's the biggest,
it might be just the biggest in North
America and you might be right.
Yeah.
They might have Chinese cities with 100
billion.
The biggest last time we looked this up,
Tokyo two,
three 30 million sentence.
It's a lot.
I saw it.
La Isn't la.
You have 20 million.
It's not official.
Well,
let's,
let's Google the world's.
Let's,
let's,
let's guess right now,
I'll tell you this.
My guests,
I have a guest on site called La County
and that city county,
it's probably 13,
14 million posts.
You're not counting Mexicans.
Uh,
am I not?
How many illegal aliens are there in
California?
Uh,
no one has a fucking club.
1 million.
Isn't that hilarious?
Yeah.
It might be true.
7 million illegals.
Yeah.
13 million regular.
Normal people.
What does that 3.8 for la La city
properties,
if that's exactly what that horse shit.
That's Los Filez.
Yeah,
he's right.
Wow.
But that's not counting.
That's,
you know,
that's not the greater metropolitan.
Yeah.
That's the thing is that La is not
really a city.
It's,
you know,
it seems like,
whoa.
What is 18 million greater Los Angeles
area?
18 million.
18 five mm.
Yeah.
That seems that's more,
see the greater,
the thing about when I say la is not a
city,
what I mean is like New York City's a
city.
It's only New York City.
Like you go there and you're like,
oh he wouldn't allow it in the city.
People say,
oh we left the city greater Tokyo is 35
million.
Oh my God.
27% of the nation's entire population.
Ooh,
wow.
Now how about China's
cities?
Cause I saw something that said they
have something like 10 or maybe more
than 10 cities in China with 20 million
or more people.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
China's cities.
There you go.
List of cities.
Wow.
Look at that.
Wait a minute.
Look at that first city,
but don't even know what fucking city
that is.
Area.
Hold on.
Population control.
I was 12 million.
700,000 okay,
so Shanghai 23 Jesus,
23 for Shanghai.
What does Beijing administrative area,
you say that's not the real,
but see the problem with this is you
leaving this up to people in China to
counter people.
Yeah.
Okay.
This city that you'd never heard of that
has 28 million tongue Pong Chong.
What does that [inaudible] I think it's
admirable.
A Tab.
Isn't that funny that if you,
if you do that,
you're an asshole.
Yeah,
of course.
You know,
if you a few incorrectly pronounce Asian
cities in a humorous way,
yeah.
You're a terrible person.
Of course you can't say Chung Chong
Chong.
You can't say that,
but I'm a bad person.
Right.
Bad person and that funny.
Guang jewel,
the Wang jewel population 2015 what do
we got here?
14 million.
Hmm.
Yeah.
According to who?
Guangzhou jeans.
They're not counting.
They're not counting for real.
They're hiding their babies to for real.
For Real.
And you're only allowed to hit women 30
million additional in migrants living in
the area for six months out of the year.
What?
Oh my God.
So they have 13 million and 30 million,
30 million people just kind of sitting
around.
They don't really live here.
There are snowbirds or you live in
there.
You live in there.
You can't say migrants.
No,
you're fucking with your numbers,
man.
It's Hollywood logic.
Or Hollywood,
uh,
arithmetic.
Yeah.
When they do Hollywood accounting,
I movies for sure have a movie that made
$100 million and they tell the actors,
I'm sorry.
No problem.
Really make that kind of money.
Yeah.
We'd love to give you what you deserve,
but we can't because the accounting,
it says we didn't make any money.
Yeah.
Hmm.
I tell you to do with record companies
too,
right?
Yep.
Have you seen soaked in bleach soaked in
bleach?
Yeah.
That's something that I have to watch.
So it's courtney.
There's a documentary about courtney
love.
Eddie Bravo in Brendan Schaub.
We're fucking raving about,
oh,
really?
Saying that she killed Kurt cobain and
her former bodyguard private
investigator.
Apparently.
Uh,
he's the one who recorded all these
conversations with her.
And it's another Netflix jammy.
No,
no.
It's a documentary,
but it's on Netflix,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
You were talking about narcos.
You just started that.
Yeah.
Smart goals really goes to shit.
So good.
It's fucking,
Netflix is killing it lately.
F is for family.
The bill burr series.
Hilarious.
Uh,
blood line.
The new,
I'm Bob and Dave show,
Mr Show.
They're doing it.
They're calling.
I don't know what they're calling bob
and Dave.
That's what it's called with Bob and
David.
It's funny,
man.
It's really good.
I saw the Aziz Ansari show.
Yeah,
it's okay.
It's been rave reviews cause he's in
sorry shows.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
I haven't seen it.
Bloodlines.
How bad do you want the whole thing?
I watched the first episode.
It's like,
it's okay.
It's,
I mean,
I had a couple of laughs,
you know who was funny in it?
Eric,
we're Haim.
Tim and Eric.
Yeah,
he's fucking hilarious.
that guy's a maniac.
He's really funny.
He's funny.
He's funny in that.
Um,
but,
but bob and David,
maybe the problem is I compared it to
Bob and David.
Maybe if I watched it on its own,
I would like it more.
But Bob and David was fucking funny.
Like really good.
I just got into the killing and,
and ran through that,
which was an AMC show that ended up on
Netflix.
Then Netflix paid for a fourth season.
Really?
That series.
I loved it.
I love the killing.
What is it about?
It's about these two Seattle homicide
detectives,
but it's really good,
you know,
storytelling that the,
basically it's them following a murder
per season and they really,
you know,
it makes it super engaging.
It's cliff hanger stuff where it ends.
You're like fucking press play on the
next one.
Isn't that crazy too?
They were lease.
That's one of the things where netflix
figured it out.
Yeah.
They just released the entire season and
won gold course binge watch it.
Yeah.
It's the cards.
Everything.
They had house of cards.
I watch house of cards too.
I've watched one and a half episodes.
It's all I've seen,
but I saw it on a plane.
American Airlines has netflix on.
Oh fuck.
Well that one.
I'll tell you.
I think you get three episodes in a
house of cards.
Consider it out.
You're done.
You're gonna Watch the whole fucking
thing if you make it that.
Yeah,
it gets better.
Pilots are tough I think.
Yeah.
As the more you watch shows like that,
you understand that pilots are tough to
introduce a world introduced,
characters make you care about what's
going on.
But once if you can get over that hurdle
and you get to the second or third and
when it's good,
like I said,
bloodline I was totally impressed with
after I got to through a couple episodes
and Fargo,
which is not a netflix thing,
but both of those seasons,
you know the,
the first season pilot of Fargo is just
one of the best pilots I've ever seen.
Fargo,
I never hear about it.
So fucking good.
Willie.
I think it might be the best show on
television.
Dammit.
Tommy.
Yes.
And I sang this.
You got to check it out.
Wow.
I'll give you,
uh,
you're going to get me,
it was how I have it on DVD,
but you can also just digitally give me
some shit and then you can also just,
you know,
on demand it's on Fx.
Really didn't give me,
give you,
give it to you.
It's an honor.
It's on Netflix.
It's on.
But if you have apple TV,
oh,
he's going to Fx fx on demand.
Oh,
watch it on apple TV is another thing
that is the shit.
Netflix is built dealers,
man and Netflix built in and it's great.
And the new one apparently is even
better.
I got the last generation.
I don't have to,
it's a new generation out of what?
Of the APPLETV.
I got the old shit.
I don't even have the new shit.
There's new shit.
There's a new one real shit to use.
It's fast.
The remote's better.
Ooh,
I might have to get a second hole.
Isn't there a way you can make a remote
with your phone?
You turn your phone into her amount.
That's some shit.
That's Jamie Shit.
Well they've been doing that with
android phones for a while.
So many android phones actually have
like an iar thing and the front making
like pointed at your tv and you can
actually change channels.
The Apple Guy was trying to get me while
I was in the store.
Like he's like,
Oh,
get these,
uh,
by these lights and then your phone can
control lights,
make them different colors.
We have those for here.
Never installed them.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well I don't have that kind of time.
I go,
dude,
come on man.
There's someone hacks my phone and turns
the fucking lights on,
off and on while I'm sleeping.
It's no fun bullshit.
That's bullshit.
It's bullshit,
man.
It's a light switch.
My wife installed these stupid fucking
light panels in my house.
They're like a little computer or you
have to touch.
It's a touchscreen thing.
It's so stupid.
She likes it because it looks cool,
but they don't click.
There's not a click,
so when you walk in a room and the
lights off,
you can't just touch it.
You have to look at it.
Find out where the,
the white light is.
Touch that.
When it turns out it's glass.
There's no tactile.
Feel.
Some horse shit.
Horse Shit.
Do you,
how do you feel about curved tvs?
Curved tvs are dog shit.
They can suck my dick.
How about that?
All right.
I was looking for an opinion and I want
a flat tv.
Goddammit.
I'm not looking at certain.
The fucking cockpit of a jet.
Yeah.
Why?
Why is it curved?
I Dunno.
What am I have to look left?
Look right,
look forward.
I don't know where to look.
I it right in front of me and flat.
They know what not too big.
How about that?
What size are you talking about?
Too?
Fucking big.
What size are you talking about?
Assholes.
They're hundred inch TV.
What the fuck are you looking?
What are you going up?
How far of you?
How about you get a smaller TV and sit
closer?
You fuck what?
You got a 100 inch TV.
We got to sit a mile away from that
fucking thing of taking the entire
image.
What about projectors?
Those are dog shit.
I've had one.
They take it,
they take a couple seconds to boot up
their stupid.
So someone steps in front of it.
You see that person on the screen.
So tvs,
the TVS are definitely the way to go.
The image is better too.
And I had a,
I've had several generations of,
of uh,
projectors.
Will you at my house?
Excuse me?
When I had the projector room?
Yes.
Yeah,
that's all gone now as a pool table in
there.
I gutted that room.
Oh,
you did?
Yeah,
it changed it.
I didn't know.
But,
um,
when,
uh,
the,
the projector was there when I got
there,
when I moved
in,
they,
uh,
it was one I had to buy it and it was
stupid.
I shouldn't have bought it.
I should have told them,
take that wonky hunk of Shit and get out
of here.
I own your house.
Kicked the bricks.
Yeah.
Uh,
but the um,
the light,
if the,
the curtains were open even a little,
you couldn't watch TV.
Yeah.
That's stuff you had to make it so dark.
You couldn't see anything.
She had to get blackout curtains.
You have blackout curtains,
you to shut the door.
If anybody opened the door while we're
watching TV,
it was so stupid.
So then we got the next generation of,
um,
projector,
which is smaller.
It's a lower profile and it was much,
much,
much better.
And then I got a big TV in there and I
was like,
these things are stupid.
Projectors are stupid.
They're just not as good.
It's not as good.
All right.
I mean,
I was thinking about it,
thinking about it.
Oh yeah,
I love,
you know,
I love watching movies and all that.
So just get it a bad ass TV.
Do you want a nice tv?
They have four k TVS now.
Like this is a four K tv.
This fucking thing looks so good that
the resolution is so high end.
It's so pretty that when you're looking
at an image,
like it doesn't get any better than
that.
You know,
my new specialist in four K oh my
goodness.
Your new special that's out this Friday
on Netflix.
January 8th.
What's it called?
It's called mostly stories.
Why'd you call it?
Mostly stories.
I just figured I tell stories and um,
you know,
even though it's not the whole special
is not stories is the story about your
doctor in this one that's in my other
special,
oh,
it's in my other special.
That one.
You know that I get a breakdown of what,
what does the best from a sound
exchange,
they go,
here's what's what people are playing
the most on Pandora.
Really?
Yeah.
And that,
that story is number one.
It's a funny fucking store.
That's the doctor Dick Story.
This one,
a real guy to write a real guy who I
finally told him that I told a story
about him and I gave it to them to
listen to.
And then he called me.
He was like,
I fucking love it.
He's like,
I just sent it to my parents and they
can't believe I talk like this to my
patient
if anybody hasn't seen it.
And we don't want to give away any
spoilers because it's a fucking
specialist call.
Completely normal,
which is on that place.
But the new one has ever a Serena
Williams bid in it.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
But this one has,
um,
has a bunch of stories of,
you know,
it has a bunch of standup.
It's a standup special,
but I have stories about my trainer in
it.
I have a story about the Jesus trainer.
Yeah.
I have him a no,
no.
And then I have a,
he's going to find out.
I think he's definitely gonna find out.
It's going to find out I have a Tyson
Mike Tyson stories in this role.
That's a great story too.
I have a story about a movie theater
fight that I got into and yeah,
there's all kinds of stories in it.
I called it mostly stories.
Um,
ask you,
um,
oh,
this is all going to tell you
no,
I d I downloaded one of your,
uh,
one of your,
cds off itunes.
I bought one of your comedy cds.
Thanks and welcome.
But there's something,
I was just in the mood for some comedy
and I know you're hilarious,
but I was,
um,
was really weird.
Uh,
my phone,
like when you have Bluetooth synced up
to your phone and your phone,
um,
if it starts when I get in my car,
I don't know what the settings are,
why it does this,
but my car,
we'll just all of a sudden start playing
like from the mold because it's set,
it's sinked up to Bluetooth and
Bluetooth for music.
So when I get in my car,
it'll all of a sudden start playing
music.
It plays your fucking Serena Williams
bit every time.
It's so bizarre.
Every time it plays it first.
So when I get in my car and I start my
car up,
I hear you.
You're the first thing that I hear every
time.
That,
so as a whole about I,
you know,
I want to die in a dumb way.
Yeah.
Like it goes right into that.
Every time it's happened to me.
Well it happens to me in my car with a
gang starr,
which I guess is probably a better,
a better than my summary for you.
It's better if you got in your car and
you started playing your shit.
He'd be like,
Hey,
listen to this pissed,
pissed,
my favorite,
my favorite shit.
But actually you knew who else it
happens too with,
with what you're saying is a,
my mother called me and she goes,
I bought your album and now every time I
get in the car it plays in.
How do I need to stop it from doing
that?
And that's my own mother.
You know,
she's fucking sick of this shit.
So that's why I wonder why song or that
one bit rather plays every time.
Every time I get in my car,
it starts off with that.
That's so it is,
that is weird.
Yeah.
It's very strange.
But it's um,
what is your gangstarr one that goes,
it's a,
I think it's above the clouds,
which makes sense because it's
Alphabetical,
right?
So,
hmm.
But gangstarr but what I mean,
I dunno man.
Yeah.
I don't know what,
what it is.
And sometimes if I plug in the phone
then it will also only play that song
and we'll let me fast forward or jumped
to another song.
What is the name of that and bid?
I think it's called a good death.
Is it?
Oh,
that's why.
Hey.
That's why I just want it to be
justified.
That's how every fucking day starts for
me.
It's because a,
yeah,
that must be a mass bay.
Well,
that's a good move.
I'm going to name all my bits.
A Big Dick Story.
Imagine if that was like what I did with
my special every fucking bit was called
a big Dick Story.
That's another big Dick.
I know.
Biggest,
my favorite big stick.
I had that thing where I,
that was kind of the idea behind when I
did my first album called thrilled where
I do like a parody of Michael Jackson's
thriller.
The whole idea,
like part of the fun of that was so that
I,
cause I knew that people who got the
album had a good chance of in their
library having it next to Michael
Jackson's,
you know that was,
that's fine.
And people send me screen grabs,
they send me screen grabs of their
library.
They're like,
you're a part of that picture is,
I love how you trimmed your neck,
but you chest is like a wall between,
you face your hair and then you have
like this bridge of no hair.
So much hair.
That should be the name of my next
album.
So much hair.
So people send you screen grabs of them,
have their phone being like it's you and
it's like me and Michael Jackson,
you know,
like side by side.
Thrilled.
That's hilarious.
Chest hair in a fucking chain.
Something about chest hair and chained
together.
Yeah.
Attract a very specific type of woman
with that look.
Oh yeah.
Chest hair and chains.
Yeah.
It's the kind that will scoop and score.
I thought that sculpin score.
Have you heard a,
if you watched F is for family yet?
I did.
I saw the first episode.
I just saw the fucking funny,
isn't it?
I love the neighbor.
Yeah,
I was thinking of him.
Oh yeah.
Gold chains.
And the driver says awesome.
Yeah.
I saw a funny series,
man killed it,
man.
That's awesome.
Apparently Louis Louis C K is going to
do an animated series now too.
Oh really?
Those gingers and taking over man
gingers are fucking run it.
Yeah,
man.
It's,
you know,
it's,
you know what it is.
It's like a lot of lack of pussy.
When you're young,
it's hard to get laid.
That tension builds up.
You get an upset focus and drive focus
and drive that redheaded focus and
drive.
So he's going to do an animated one.
Yeah.
He's apparently going to do an animal.
You went to animated series,
man.
It's so you could get away with so much.
I mean,
think about what South Park has gotten
away with the stuff that they can do.
What [inaudible] and butthead dead.
Yeah.
Back in the day.
When aren't they gone to Redo Beavis and
butthead?
They did.
Right.
But nobody cared anymore.
But he's doing that hbo show.
Mike Judd?
Yeah.
What?
Silicone Valley.
Oh,
that's right.
His,
that's a good show.
That's another funny show.
Is this the best time ever to be just a
fucking loser?
Sits in front of the TV without doubt.
This is the best,
best tv shows ever,
ever.
TV has for a while now.
Just leapt over.
Moving same cinema.
Just not even close.
Not even close.
I think about what you can do with a TV
man.
Well,
the thing about TV is like something
like game of thrones.
It's like a new movie every week and
it's tied together.
Yeah.
In a movie.
I mean,
how much can you really get attached to
a character in a two hour film?
It kind of can,
but not like the way you can't over 10
1520 episodes season for sure.
He knew what else I like that these
television shows,
whether it's narcos or whether it's game
of thrones,
they're largely unknown actors.
So you associate them with the actual
character instead of going,
Oh,
here's beneath old del Toro playing
another crazy guy.
Right,
right,
right.
That happens a lot.
Yes.
That's big man,
because when I go to the movies and I
see Tom Cruise,
I'm seeing Tom fucking cruise.
I'm not seeing some mad scientist.
I'm not seeing a private agent,
no secret agent.
I'm seeing Tom Parking cruise.
He's famous or Bradley Cooper or
Jennifer Lawrence.
I'm seeing them.
I know it's them.
You can't lie to me.
It's why those actors that were really
that really get into play and parts
stand out so much like the way that
Phillip Seymour Hoffman used to play
roles.
You lose yourself in his role because he
was so committed to not being the actor.
He was the park.
Daniel Day Lewis is my favorite example
of that fucking guy.
When he did that boxer moving,
he did nothing but box for a year,
really for a year.
All we did was go to the boxing gym
every day and train.
He looked.
He's the only guy that I've ever seen in
a movie where he actually looked like a
real boxer when he was doing the scenes.
It was like if you watched the fighter
with Marky Mark Wahlberg and he's
playing,
um,
I'm a tour guide.
Micky Ward,
he playing Micky Ward,
he doesn't live it.
Got Boxer and I say,
God knows how to throw punches.
Jillian Hall.
Do you think he looked like a box?
I didn't see that movie.
Yeah,
the Marky mark movie.
He doesn't look like a guy who's
actually been boxing.
He looks like a guy who knows how to
throw punches.
But there's a big difference between a
guy who knows how to throw punches and a
guy who knows how to throw punches,
anticipating that so many punches back
and the idea of an actual boxer,
there's a difference between knowing
that a guy's going to stand in front of
you like a rocky movie or a guy who
looks like a boxer.
And Daniel Day Lewis was the only guy
I've ever seen in a movie that actually
looked like a boxer.
He,
this is him.
This is him jumping rope.
But maybe there's a,
Oh,
that's him actually jumping rope.
Yeah.
Look how good he's jumping rope.
Holy Shit.
That shit,
man.
Yeah.
That guy's an animal man.
He really is an animal.
That motherfucker,
he,
when he did that,
uh,
my left foot,
he was in character like for like a
year.
Well,
they said he was like that for,
there will be blood stays in character.
That's probably annoying as fuck it's
gotta be.
Imagine if you do it in a movie like
Lincoln and nobody gives a shit.
How about offset,
you know,
lunches or dinner with them.
Oh,
have a milkshake and they're like,
come on.
Hey Ben.
Sorry.
Yeah,
it's,
it's gonna wear on you score.
And seven years ago,
and nobody gave a fuck about that movie.
More people cared about the,
the Abraham Lincoln versus the vampire
movie.
Abraham Lincoln,
vampire hunter.
More people cared about that movie then.
Then the Daniel Day,
Lewis Abraham Lincoln went,
yeah,
I believe that.
What is that?
We don't give a fuck about historical
movies.
I don't know.
Sometimes they take off.
Right.
I think part of it is nameless this,
well,
no,
I think part of it is now is that we
have seen a lot like there's a point
where you go,
I know even though it might be worth
telling,
I've seen a number of Holocaust movies
or I've seen a number of civil rights,
you know,
American story like so when those come
out go,
I kind of know the story,
right?
So I think that's where the,
the interest,
the box office goes down and people go,
well I know,
I know this story and you can retell it
or tell it in a new way or interesting
way.
But people feel like I got it right.
I've seen the story does,
it doesn't feel like new,
but it was for for a moment it's boring.
We don't want to hear about it.
Went on to hear about history.
I want space ships and I want aliens and
laser beams and explosions.
Did you say a force awakens?
Yes,
I did.
What'd you think of a date?
Haven't seen it yet.
You should before I tell you everything
that happened.
I do want to see it.
It's good,
man.
I was obsessed with him and I was a kid.
I enjoy the shit out of it.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a perfect blend of new and old.
It's a perfect homage.
It captures the essence of the original
films,
but with much more updated special
effects,
graphic storytelling and acting is
really good too.
There's nothing bad about it.
I loved it.
I've used,
started watching,
we were talking about netflix making of
a murderer.
No,
I have not get your entire life
together.
I know.
I need to.
Everybody keeps fucking telling me.
That is the number one thing that people
tweet me about.
Other than that,
I'm wrong about Bernie Sanders.
I'm not my party candidate.
He not say 90%.
He said he's okay with it.
It's not too much.
If it's over a certain amount,
I'm not done with it.
Feel the burn.
You're going to,
it's shit your pants.
I keep saying,
I keep hearing that.
Um,
apparently I've listened to a radio lab
podcast that talked about the exact same
story.
It is,
right.
I looked it up.
It came out in like 2013 they weren't,
they left out,
uh,
all the corruption going on in the
movie.
Yeah.
The state side of the story and the,
the states side of the story and the
woman's side of the story who accused
the man of rape and she thought,
I dunno the level of conspiracy involved
in this.
It's just,
it's mind blowing.
Yeah.
The radio lab thing didn't cover that at
all.
That's what really,
that kind of sucks.
They couldn't have though.
They do.
Radio lab only had an hour,
two hours.
He's got to do 10 episodes that same
little over an hour.
He'd see.
That's where something like Netflix
fucking shines.
Yeah.
Cause you can't do that anywhere else.
They won't let you know,
like my new special six hours.
Wow.
That's amazing.
Are you naked in all of it and most of
it,
beginning of the end was a lot of
asshole shots or I don't know that
there's a lot of what I tried to do.
I do the diaper change style.
I'm going to do the face down.
I do both.
I had a guy come up to me at the fucking
Improv the other day,
asked me to do a comedy and a nudist
camp.
He's like,
it's amazing.
We,
everyone who performs,
they perform naked.
I go,
Oh yeah,
okay.
Uh Huh.
And he goes,
who are you interested in doing?
I go,
nope.
See Ya.
He goes,
oh,
come on man.
You,
I go,
hey dude,
you're not going to see my cock.
Yeah.
Okay.
You want to,
yeah.
This is your elaborate method.
Guy was clearly gay by the way.
He was going for that car.
Then you have us.
Who was the guy that was dying to see
you?
Or was that a,
was that a gym or something and you have
a guy somewhere that was eyeballing you,
something like that.
Was it working out every day,
bro.
But I mean,
you know,
I did just scout at a,
uh,
at a gay gym for a while when I was on
news radio.
I worked at,
at a gold's gym on coal,
but like the same,
like the same guy waiting all the call.
That wasn't,
no,
that was in Jujitsu,
Jujitsu.
That was the sky.
Well we had to kick that guy out.
He was just like hang back.
He would wait for me to get dressed but
he waited for everybody to get trust and
he would harass guys.
He was like say a bunch of creepy sexual
shit to people when they were changing.
Yeah.
Which uh,
it's end.
He also would go and do Jujitsu and
purposely get his ass kicked.
Dicey.
You're manhandling them.
We want it to like you barely fight back
man.
Like I remember he roll with this one
guy and the guy tapped him like really
quick and they got to realize he wasn't
fighting back and like looked at them
and they looked at and the,
and the guy tried to keep going and
goes,
no,
I'm dumb and we're not doing this,
doing this.
First of all,
you just came all over yourself.
That's making me a couple.
He said to my friend Brad,
he said,
sometimes I just come here to get my ass
kicked.
Come on man.
This is not the place.
And this is Brett was one of the guys
that got him kicked out of there because
he would just say creepy sexual shit
though.
That's crazy.
He would say weird shit.
The guys,
you know,
like one time,
uh,
I,
I wear,
I would wear a jockstrap and then,
uh,
over my jock strap,
I would put a cup on [inaudible],
you know,
and the cop goes in a jockstrap he goes,
yeah,
you were a two jock straps.
And I just looked at him like,
why are you staring at me getting
changed and commenting?
I'm on a blighted.
Yeah,
shut the fuck up,
man.
This is weird.
And the way we do it,
it's like this longing looking at his
face.
Like he's just hoping that you just just
pull your car got and just stuff it and
get mug
throat.
Tell us sweet freedom.
There was none of that.
That's another thing about the evolution
of porn to things that have happened
that have been pretty radical.
One,
no one has hair pussy anymore,
puts her hair,
puts it,
turns out the war.
Yeah,
it's gone.
The radical crazy girl has a little
landing strip.
Oh my God,
she's crazy.
Like a little Bush.
He like some Bush.
It's not that I like it or dislike it.
I have no problem with not getting pubic
hair in my mouth,
but what I'm thinking is kids today,
they don't know what it's like to get a
pubic hair stuck in between your teeth.
Yeah.
They don't want to set up yes for us.
Sure.
That feeling.
Yeah.
We have it in your Tanya so he can't get
it out and even if you get it out,
you think he's still in there.
You never get it out.
You actually don't use that move for
anything else than removing pubic hairs
from your mouth.
Maybe if you bite a Napkin,
if you take a Napkin and bite into it
and chew it and then he got up,
but why would you do that?
Right,
but you eat a lot of pussy have to
hairs.
I spent a lot of hairs in my youth.
Sure that somewhere online it just
stopped.
It's silence.
The fucking,
the trees were all chopped down like
what happened?
What happened to the forest?
Just stuffy in there.
It's weird.
It's just stopped growing pussy hair.
When you saw it.
Girls get one of yours and then they
stop.
You're like,
could you get back to it?
And they're like,
what?
But some,
some change happen both in pornography
and in people.
And it's almost like pornography became
more popular because of like blockbuster
and vhs tapes.
Sure.
Remember they have those local video
stores.
Of course you have to go through the
fucking saloon doors to get to with that
open a year,
young,
uh,
adrenaline rush walking through those
doors.
You feel people don't,
I know if you were on,
if you were visiting someone in prison
and you had to go to jail lockdown area,
yeah.
It really was.
I remember buying to buying porn in
those.
And you know,
you buy,
if you go to a porn store,
it's funny,
but if you go to a regular store that
has porn and you buy a porn and then you
get the checkout person who was like
totally judging you,
you're a real fucking pig.
You know that.
You can be so nervous.
Oh,
so nor honorable.
I remember the,
uh,
some of the checkout person one time was
like,
you want me to throw away the box for
you?
A lot of people don't like the box.
I was like,
I'll take the puck,
put it in a fucking bag,
let's go to the box.
Might collect them,
collect the boxes,
a frame,
the boxes.
If you're going to be an order,
how am I going to know the order if I
don't have the box?
I need a box.
Yeah.
Um,
the saloon door thing.
So I think people started buying them.
They started renting them,
right?
And they started taking them home and
then they started going,
what's all the hair?
Yeah.
And then something happened where the
industry recognized that it's looks
weird when you see all this asshole hair
and you're good to fucking camera three
inches away from it.
And some dudes,
hairy ass and his ball bag or slapping
up against her area.
And I'm like,
look,
we've got to clean this up.
We've got to clean this up.
Okay.
And so they somewhere along the line
don't on what year it was the eighties
maybe they started all the shaving down
like ace and had some hair.
I think it was to me I think it was the
shift in the high def.
Ah,
you might be right.
Took the airway well it's also people
got bored with the regular product.
So we were talking about earlier like
why are they still making porn?
Well obviously it came a point in time
where they had to shift from just two
people meeting the pizza guy.
Come on in,
I don't have any money but I can pay you
in another one.
Something happened along the way were
porn itself changed?
Like they got tired of those scenarios
and then it became like rough porn and
gagging and Mascara running.
It's not,
those are really crazy still.
Oh my God I saw this one with this girl.
They laid her down on a bed and her head
hung off the edge of the bed and guys
just took turns.
Just mouth fucking
are balls into her nose and slobber and
like she was like puking up saliva,
like coughing and spitting and that she
would and they would just be right back
in there and the next guy would do it.
And these guys were these giant cocked
black guys with these big meaty acids.
Pound her fucking mouth.
Yeah.
It was just whoa,
Whoa,
whoa man.
Who's asking for that?
Someone's clearly asking for that.
Do you think they just had figured out,
you know,
we got to present this in a different
way?
I think it's probably the people that do
the porn,
like we're talking about mass hardcore
being so fucking crazy.
I think they just get so bored with sex.
They're like,
no up,
I'm opening your ass home and throw my
keys in there that people have.
Like we're gonna play Jacks and when to
throw the jacks in your ass haul
something happened.
There's a proportion to that.
Yeah.
It went from missionary to like lay on
your back,
you know,
get a dog and then it's like,
tongue my balls from underneath.
Let's go ask her mouth like someone was
the first worst Nigga.
I got an idea.
Yeah.
And then asked her mouth was born.
Is that safe to do so?
Genre,
ATM.
It's a genre,
you know milfs cause like a,
a bunch of different genres.
Guilty.
You can find these genres.
Kim An yeah,
Jesus Christ.
60 plattsmouth but because of that,
the images that people saw in
pornography changed the way people take
care of their pubic hair.
Yeah.
It's 100% what it was.
That's the influence.
Pornography changed the way women trim
their pubic hair.
Maybe guys too.
Yeah,
definitely trim,
trimming it at all before.
Do you manscape down there?
Sure.
Is it like your neck and the thriller
thing where it's like beard,
beard,
beard.
It's no hair,
hair,
chest,
clean cock and clean bikini line.
Hairy legs.
It would,
that would be so it just not as crazy
down there.
But yeah,
I definitely do some maintenance man.
You know,
I like,
I like having a pretty clean ball bag.
That's a good move.
And then you know,
hair grows on the shaft.
I trimmed that off too.
How much hair it grows in your chef.
There's like my beard.
Like this is no joke.
He's a wolf man Werewolf.
I'll shave all around it and then we'll
trim all around that to save your
asshole.
No,
I did it once.
I had it waxed once.
I did it once when I tweeted about it
and people got mad at me.
Why?
Oh,
it was great.
I got to say I want to go back to it
shaving your asshole.
I had it waxed.
And why did you do that for a radio
show.
But what radio show?
Bob and Tom,
they waxed your asshole.
But the um,
explained further please.
I met,
they made some comment about waxing and
hair and I said something to them like,
well the next time I'm in town I would
do that,
you know,
to my ass.
Cause I,
I'd heard about how,
how ups your wife game so much.
Oh yeah.
What a match.
Well,
they did it,
it was fine.
Like it wasn't that crazy
to do.
It wasn't as paint know who did it and
they had a uh,
local people that that wax male or a
female female,
a girl saw your asshole.
She waxed it.
Yeah.
She put that in there.
She got in there.
Did she have like those rubber made
gloves?
She had some type of glove on.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
And then,
you know,
she was putting hot wax in my ass.
If she didn't,
you'd be like,
um,
yeah.
Are you professional?
She's pulling it off with her teeth and
then,
but here's the thing,
users or finger nails for mips it away
like a sticker.
The memory isn't even getting waxed.
It's how great the wiping was for six
weeks after that,
six whole weeks until it stubble starts
kicking in.
Yeah.
You have unbelievable taint itch.
Yes.
The taint itch was other level,
but I didn't even know what it was like
to not to,
to wipe a few times.
Yeah.
It'd be like,
yeah,
I'm done.
Because when you have a hairy ass,
oh shit under the top of your head,
a picture of that,
that's what you're doing with your hair
yet never quite get done.
Roll of toilet paper for a normal shit
to clean my ass.
So disgust.
So one time I decided I was shaving my
ball bag and a I trim first and then I
get in the shower and then I use a
razor.
Right.
So a razor in my ball back.
No.
You know,
so I can get in there.
And so I lifted my leg up,
some quite flexible,
right?
I put my leg up on the wall and just
looked down there and just started
shaving away.
It just,
the visual is amazing.
Hacking fucking trees out of my asshole.
First of all,
I couldn't believe how long my asshole
Harris,
yeah.
Gets lost.
It gets like,
uh,
like more than a beard.
Yeah.
Like we're crazy beard.
Like maybe like a Rasputin type beard.
But how'd you feel after that?
First of all,
my farts changed the sound.
I was like,
I couldn't,
but it's almost like before I was like
farting through the forest and now it's
like all my farts like wet and so cause
it gets muffled with that.
Hey,
they sounded different.
Yeah,
they stayed literally sounded different
and it will louder now that they had
beautiful beef.
Creem was coming out of peak.
There's this guy that we found on our
podcasts.
What's his name?
His name is Thursday lane.
Oh this is another guy.
This isn't the other guy.
The finance not kicking ass rapper.
This guy,
this guy is named his,
yeah,
his name was,
his name is diego,
but he goes by Thursday lane and his a
fucking name.
Yeah,
he gets,
I got a rap name and he wants to be,
he wants to do fart fetish porn.
That's his dream.
So he posted all these videos about how
much he loves farts and that's how we
got in touch with him.
And he has a description for whatever
type of hair color you have.
He associates it with a different type
of cream or broth.
That's the smell to him.
So if you have brown hair,
you have beef cream farts.
And if you have this is him.
This is him.
Yeah.
Thursday lane marries a fart.
What?
Yeah.
This is play this,
what does that mean?
You'll see Mary's a fart
if you're a diabetic cock pit.
Your meat marrying.
Get farts where you're like the beef
chicken.
Spicy Korean.
Yeah.
Can I'm Mary y'all farce the light
please.
Please.
What is I put his hair.
It's different.
Ready?
One,
two.
Oh Wow.
Other than made up for life.
Thank you.
These are the three lines on that.
So Guy Farts in his face and he gets
super excited.
Yeah.
He loves it.
Right?
I mean you don't understand.
So you know if you have,
um,
he really does like it.
Oh,
he loves it.
He's not kidding.
No,
he just did a flip bullies.
Even the way Jesus Christ,
let's face it,
is eating that guys asked one of the guy
who was farting in his face is gay or
not.
I don't think he is.
He works for that.
Cause we talked to that company.
To company.
Yeah,
because we,
we talked about them on a,
our podcast kind of company,
and we talking about it,
it's hot movies.com or something like
that.
So they,
they,
they heard him on our podcast and then
they contacted him and shot that
interview.
Um,
but he has a description for every hair
color.
So if you have,
if you have white hair,
he is,
you're a silver trout cream.
If you have blond hair,
your chicken cream if you have.
So he associates this,
it's really intense and he has a whole
list of and calls your farts.
Beautiful guppies.
I'm like,
what the fuck is wrong with him?
He loves farts.
But did you ask him how this all
happened?
Yeah,
he,
he likes to ramble though,
so I couldn't really keep up,
you know,
it kind of goes off on some stuff and
you on the phone with them,
not real life.
Right.
So he was just,
I was like,
all right man,
we got to pull this in.
But,
um,
I,
I even said like,
oh,
I feel like I got a little,
I got a little beef cream today.
He goes,
hmm.
He,
there's all types of people out there in
this wacky world.
There's so many wacky people,
and if you met this guy and he was like,
I love far,
nothing gives me off more.
If that's what gets me.
When people say they're bothered by
something that like,
would it bother you that that's what he
likes?
No.
Oh Shit,
we're comedians.
Yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
I mean,
that is what it is.
We're freaks.
We're not regular.
That's true.
I mean,
there's a lot of freaks out there that
have regular jobs that don't mind.
Don't care either,
but we're freaks.
Yeah.
You know,
in terms of society.
Yeah.
We're about as freaky as it gets.
That's true.
We're,
we're looking for this stuff.
I mean,
you contacted this guy.
Yeah.
He wanted him on your show.
You get the throat master.
What's her name?
Through the zillow.
Yeah.
You had her on your show.
True.
We
were seeking it out.
Ah,
and loving it.
Of course.
That's the best.
I wish I met somebody like that
everyday.
Why not?
Right?
Yeah.
Just like a professional cycler.
I got pee.
Oh,
well,
we're done.
Anyway.
It's five o'clock man.
Yeah,
we do three fucking hours.
God Damn a girl.
That was fun.
That was,
what are you doing here?
Right here?
Monitor.
You're paying,
you're turning that on.
I'm turning it on and go pee.
Why?
Well,
I'm just,
I'm a vlogger man.
Oh,
you're blogging.
I'm flogging.
I'm,
you know,
the people started saying that.
Excuse me.
I'm not in support of people saying it.
I don't mind reading out of it.
I make fun of it.
And blogging.
Blogging is a funny term to me.
Uh,
feel weird standing there pointing at
that.
You have a handle on it.
Like it's a gun.
It's a,
I've had it stick out of the jacket by
the way.
And I've seen some people's eyes go.
Let me ask you this.
Yeah.
Why that and not just a phone,
cause it seems like a phone would make
it easier to upload the videos just as
good.
It's not this,
this picture quality's got to be better,
but must better.
Yeah.
Jamie,
easier to edit those videos that Tara,
it's actually not so easy to get that
the video off your iphone.
You've got to connect it to your thing
and you can just take that card out and
plugging in your computer.
Oh.
It's not like it's super hard,
but it's a little bit easier to deal
with those.
Okay.
I see what you're saying.
Well,
you know,
I would think that just having a phone,
it's easy.
I always have a phone.
You're right.
But I think this picture is better.
Yeah.
Oh,
I'm sure it's better.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean that thing sticks out.
That sticks out the,
the,
the lens sticks out.
It's,
yeah,
that's real.
It's real.
It's a real shit.
Alright,
I'll knock it off.
All right.
No,
you don't have to knock it off.
Well,
you know,
um,
I just want to say everybody,
if you're watching this,
yes,
you need to,
you need to watch Tom Segura on Netflix
starting January 8th.
It's called mostly stories and it's
fucking hilarious.
And I've seen most of what mostly
stories is,
and it's gut wrenchingly hilarious.
You fucks go before you watch.
F is for family or Narcos or any of that
shit.
Watch mostly stories.
January 8th Friday on Netflix.
All right,
folks.
Thanks.
Rogan podcast is over.
Um,
Tom Segura on twitter,
or you could also listen to your mom's
house with,
uh,
Tom and his lovely wife,
Christina p.
Congratulations on the Little Bambino.
The little Thomas A.
Good or what is giant hall?
All right,
fuckers.
That's it for the week.
We'll be back next week with lots of
awesome people buy by.
Big Kiss.
Yeah.